Machen wir einfach eine Fußballkneipe. Und zwar ohne Kompromisse, ohne Wenn und Aber, Fußball pur.
Und man braucht, glaube ich, eine Stunde, um alle Details ausgemacht zu haben. Man kriegt kein Tageslicht, finde ich super. Auf zwei Beemern laufen zwei Spiele. Man kann sich also voll auf, ehrlich gesagt, auf Fußball und Saufen konzentrieren. Und das ist eine super Sache. Man kriegt Schnitzel, da kann man noch eine Familie von der Straße reinholen. Zauberhafter Wirt in einem alten Osborn-Trikot von Waffel-Bochum aus den 70er Jahren. Also ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht weg, wenn ich nicht hier hingekommen wäre.
Ich muss das wirklich schon mal sagen, ich bin hier restlos begeistert von dieser Kneipe. Ich habe schon viele erlebt, wenn ich vor allen Dingen auf Rundfahre und kann da nicht Fußball gucken durch die Mine, dann sah ich immer, ich spreche mit dem Hotel ab, wo eine Kneipe ist. Ich hätte doch gerne, wenn dann gegen mich so ihr Hetz wirft und die anderen sagen, ich bin doch für ich kann zurückhetzen. Das hört doch einfach dazu, wenn man den Rahmen des Verträchtlichen nicht überschreitet. Wenn ihr den Ziehkäse schon aller Ziegen nennt, dann würde ich dieses große Schnitzel und aller Kali demnächst. Hier auf der Karte stehen.
Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer im Tribünengespräch im Rasenfunk. Wir nehmen heute die 14. Folge des Tribünengesprächs auf und sind an einem ganz besonderen Ort in einer ganz besonderen Runde. Zu dieser gehört unter anderem der liebe Frank. Hallo Frank.
Hallo Max.
Frank, wo sind wir denn? Wie sieht es denn hier rund um uns aus?
Nach Fußball. Ziemlich eindeutig. Ich glaube, wir sind in einem Raum, der vielleicht so, ich kann es gar nicht sagen, 200 Quadratmeter groß ist. Und neben vielen Stühlen in der Mitte sind die Wände voll mit Postern, Trikots, Schals.
Kein Zentimeter ohne Fußballbezug.
Und wahnsinnig vielen Zeitungsausschnitten und was auch immer. Ein Fußball-Fan-Paradies.
Absolut. Ich war schon häufiger hier und trotzdem entdecke ich immer wieder neue Dinge. Wir sind im Stadion an der Schleißheimer Straße. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das ist eine Fußballkneipe in München. Ich denke, eine der bekanntesten Deutschlands. Wahrscheinlich sind die beiden Inhaber zu höflich, das selber zuzugeben. Aber das ist hier in München so ein bisschen das Fußballmecker, zu dem man hinpilgern kann. Und wir wollen heute über Fußballkneipen sprechen und wie man eigentlich auf die Idee kommt, sowas hier aufzuziehen und woher auch eigentlich diese ganzen Dinge hier an den Wänden kommen. Und deshalb freuen wir uns sehr, dass wir die beiden Inhaber hier begrüßen können. Zum einen den Holle. Servus, Holle.
Servus.
Und den Michl. Servus, Michl. Kann man schon so sagen, dass es eine der bekanntesten Fußballkneipen Deutschlands ist, oder? Mir würde nur noch die Freunde bei Essen einfallen.
Keine Konkurrenz.
Die sind ein bisschen anders. Aber vielleicht ist es so. Wir hatten das Glück, so wie mit dir, dass wir ab und zu mal in den Medien waren. Aber wir müssen gleich den ersten Fehler feststellen. Leider keine 200 Quadratmeter, sonst würden wir nämlich doppelt so viel für Sky zahlen. Ja. Sind nur 80.
Aber habt ihr ausgemessen, die 80?
Das hat Sky ausgemessen.
Ja, das kommt dann mit dem Meterstab vorbei.
Mit dem Meterstab, ja, genau. Laser-Messgerät. Und dann wird alles ganz genau ausgemessen. Auch der Bereich hinter der Bar zählt dann dazu. Ja, da packen wir auch meistens irgendwie so noch 30, 40 Gäste hinter die Bar, dass es sich auch wirklich irgendwie lohnt für den Preis, weil sonst wird es schwierig, das zu refinanzieren.
Ach, ist ja interessant. Da ist mir ja schon mitten im Detailthema drin, wie es eigentlich ist, eine Fußballkneipe zu betreiben. Das wollen wir heute mal mit euch besprechen und dazu gehört ja irgendwie auch die Frage, wie kommt man überhaupt auf die Idee, eine Fußballkneipe zu machen? Denn meines Wissens nach kann man das ja nirgendwo studieren. Oder kann man das irgendwo studieren?
Also, ich glaube, ich habe studiert. Das Studium war sehr, sehr erfolglos, aber ich konnte Kneipen in eben Essen studieren. In dem Ruhrgebiet gibt es ja viele schöne Kneipen. Und da habe ich auch so ein paar Anregungen mitgenommen. Zum Beispiel Bier verkaufen, viel Bier verkaufen, Bierdeckel, auf die geschrieben wird, ein Wirt, der Sachen durchs Mikrofon durchsagt. Da fing das schon so an, aber da gab es die 11 Freunde-Bahn noch nicht.
Aber dann bist du ja nicht mit dem Ziel nach München gekommen, hier in der Fußballkneipe aufzumachen, oder?
Das war eigentlich nicht das Ziel. Ich wollte eigentlich so werden wie du.
Das habe ich noch nie gehört in meinem Leben. Das finde ich schön, dass das aufgenommen wurde.
Ich habe damals dann ein Volontariat gekriegt bei Sport.de. Das gibt es jetzt auch nicht mehr, weil in der Zeit des Volontariats habe ich dann gleich mal zwei Insolvenzen mitgemacht. Also das hat alles top funktioniert.
Wann war denn das?
Das war 2000. Lang her. Irgendwann war ich dann aber trotzdem in München, hier in der Gegend. Ich habe im Vollmond – so hieß der Laden früher – 2002 morgens um 9 Uhr WM geguckt. Mit zwei anderen. Es gab auch Kaffee und der Vollmond wurde eben meine absolute Stammkneipe. Ich habe mir dann auch die Wohnung in der Gegend gesucht.
Du hast dir die Wohnung nach deiner Kneipe ausgesucht?
Ja.
Das ist eine Konsequenz.
Es gab damals schon die Umgebungssuche und ja, da war ich konsequent. Umso schlimmer, dass 2006, nach der WM, der Wirt mir gesagt hat, wir müssen leider schließen, weil er gehofft hat, es gibt noch mal, er hat ab und zu mal Fußball gezeigt und hat natürlich auf die WM gehofft. Und die WM war aber für ihn ein ziemlicher Flop, weil vier Wochen Sonne.
Und dann alle draußen.
Alle draußen. Das ist so an ihm vorbei gegangen. Ich glaube, er hat dann auch nur noch irgendwo draußen geguckt und hat gesagt, ja, jetzt bin ich pleite. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, Alter, ist nicht, kannst meine Stammkneipe nicht zumachen. Und so hat sich das Ganze dann entwickelt. Also er hat mich dann halt gefragt, ja, was soll ich machen? Hast du eine Idee? Steigst du mit ein? Und meine Gastrokenntnis war Null. Und dann habe ich gesagt, klar, logisch, logisch, Idee habe ich.
Bier trinken kann ich auch.
Bier trinken kann ich auch. Zapfen nicht bis heute. Musste meine damalige Lebensgefährtin noch davon überzeugen. Das habe ich durch dreitägiges Schweigen hingekriegt, bis sie gesagt hat, ja, dann mach halt die scheiß Kneipe. Sie hat auch Recht behalten, weil die Beziehung ist natürlich daran gescheitert. Aber das Stadion gibt es immer noch. Und wir haben am Samstag, Freitag, haben wir schon wieder Geburtstag.
Wie viele Jahre werden es dann? 11. 2006 war also die Gründung.
Die Stammkneipe übernehmen, das hört sich für mich ehrlich gesagt noch am Schicksal an, was auch viele meiner Germanistik-Kommilitonen so im Sinn hatten.
Hatte ich ja auch studiert.
Wir haben wirklich viel gemeinsam heute. Aber du hattest dann, also Sport-Ehe hast du gesagt, ihr hattet zwei Insolvenzen, aber du bist ja trotzdem mit dem Sportjournalismus irgendwie hängen geblieben, oder? Also das war schon eine Sache, die du am Anfang noch parallel dazu gemacht hast.
Bin ich, ja, ja. Ich war dann kurze Zeit in Frankfurt, auch bei einem unglaublich sinnlosen Portal, das dann auch nach einem halben Jahr Insolvenz angemeldet hat. Ich wurde da aber noch irgendwie zum Redakteur. Es gab damals keine Vorgaben. Und dann hat mir ein Kumpel den damaligen Traumjob für mich verschafft, beim Doppelpass als Unterstützer des Net Man, wenn den noch jemand kennt.
Ach, ist das der, der die Reaktion aus dem Netz sammelt?
Genau. Das durfte ich machen. Nur durfte ich es nicht moderieren. Das haben dann Menschen wie Sascha Bandermann und so weiter gemacht. Sondern ich musste immer unter den Tisch, wenn die Einblendung war. Nein. War super. Das war großartig.
Ach, ernsthaft? Du warst ja wirklich daneben, neben ihm mit.
Every fucking Sunday war ich da draußen und muss dann immer unter den Tisch. Und habe ihm vorher eben die Beiträge irgendwie…
Die Tweets ausgedruckt.
Tweets gab es damals ja noch nicht. Wann war das? Das war damals noch über Foren. 2002, 2003.
2002 war das.
Also habe ich bis 2004 gemacht. Da habe ich mein Ziel erreicht, war vier Wochen in Lissabon, habe mir eine schöne Zeit gemacht beim EM-Talk. Und danach habe ich gesagt, jetzt habe ich alles erreicht.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass du beim Doppelpass gearbeitet hast. Das ist ja unser großes Vorbild, der Doppelpass. Wir wollen immer so sein wie der Doppelpass. Deswegen nehme ich auch viele Folgen unterm Tisch auf.
Und es war auch garantiert nichts gelogen von den Beiträgen, die davor gelesen wurden.
Ja gut, aber das war in den Zeiten vorsorgen, da wurde da noch viel optimiert. Also Leserbriefe werden ja auch mal gerne geschrieben in den Redaktionen selbst. Und auch beim Dopaphone weiß ich noch damals, dass ich, also manche Stimmen kamen mir vertraut vor nach einer Weile Doppelpass. Damals habe ich den Doppelpass noch häufig gesehen.
Ist schon so. Meine Kumpels haben sich auch immer gefreut, dass sie erwähnt wurden, dass angeblich was geschrieben haben.
Okay und dann Fußballkneipe aufgemacht. Sah das von Anfang an so aus wie hier, also das quasi wirklich – wir werden noch ein paar Fotos machen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und unter der Folge verlinken – hier ist wirklich jeder Zentimeter genutzt mit irgendwelchen Devotionalien. Woher kommt denn der ganze Kram?
Es war am Anfang natürlich ganz anders. Also es war sehr kahl an den Welten. Ich hatte auch den Anspruch, wir gestalten das eher puristisch, so ein paar schöne Accessoires an den Wänden, sah aber ganz ehrlich scheiße aus. Und ja, dann haben die Gäste nach und nach einfach immer mehr Sachen gebracht.
Ach cool, das kam von den Gästen?
Ja, die meisten Sachen sind wirklich von den Gästen. Wir haben das dann immer wieder zusammengestellt, neu und neue Sachen dazu aufgehängt und wieder anders angeordnet und nochmal anders angeordnet. Jetzt sind wir gerade in der für uns etwas traurigen Phase, dass wir keine Zeit haben, weil wir haben noch so viele Sachen, die wir aufhängen müssen und Sachen wieder austauschen. Da haben wir ein sehr schlechtes Gewissen vielen Gästen gegenüber.
Ja gut, aber das kommt ja irgendwie mit dem Job. Bisschen was zu tun ist ja schon.
Bisschen was zu tun ist schon. Ich muss ab und zu Bier bestellen. Es ist genauso, wie sich das die Gäste vorstellen, dass wir tagsüber ja eigentlich nichts zu tun haben und abends in Tresen stehen und trinken.
Ja, es ist ein einfacher Job und deswegen bist du ja dann auch irgendwann dazu gekommen, Michl, oder hast du gesehen, wie sich der Holle einfach doch hier lauer entspannt.
Ja, das habe ich natürlich gesehen, dass sich das Holle hier ganz gemütlich eingerichtet hat. Ich dachte, das mache ich eigentlich irgendwie genauso. Abends ein bisschen Bier trinken, Fußball gucken, ein bisschen mit Gästen reden und das war es dann eigentlich. Also ein sehr angenehmer Job, muss man sagen. Schon ganz einfach eigentlich. Kann eigentlich auch jeder. Also, es liegt immer ja an Holle.
Moment mal, germanistisch zu verstehen, sind die Krone der Schöpfung, wenn du mich fragst.
Er hat es ja nicht abgeschlossen.
Dass die Ironie in Podcasts nicht funktioniert, haben wir vorhin schon gesagt.
Ja, dann warte mal, dann muss ich kurz den Schalter umschalten.
Wie war denn dein Weg hierher?
Mein Weg war ein bisschen anders als der von Holle, weil ich also eigentlich kann ich nicht sagen, dass es meine Stammkneipe war. Ich war zwar häufiger mal hier, allerdings nie jetzt irgendwie zu irgendwelchen Champions-League-Spielen, wo dann hier brechend voll ist. Das war mir eigentlich immer irgendwie zu viel.
Und manche Sachen hast du auch vergessen, kannst du dich erinnern?
Ja, ich habe auch manche Sachen vergessen. Das ist tatsächlich ganz lustig, weil zum zehnjährigen letztes Jahr haben wir eine Bildergalerie zusammengestellt aus zehn Jahren Stadion. Und beim Bilderdurchschauen habe ich mich dann irgendwie 2008 oder so bei einer Elf-Freunde-Lesung entdeckt und ich kann mich bis heute nicht dran erinnern, dass ich da war. Aber Beweisfotos gibt es. Ja, sprich, ich war schon ab und zu mal irgendwie hier, war auch mal bei Fußballspielen hier, aber immer dann, wenn es hier nicht so wahnsinnig voll war und guten Holle, das ist jetzt nicht so schwierig, den irgendwie hier kennenzulernen, weil der labert ja eh jedenfalls. Hat ja sonst nichts zu tun, wie gesagt.
Total kommunikativ hat er.
Genau, total kommunikativ. Ich kannte ihn aber auch so ein bisschen von seiner Zeit bei Premiere und danach dann Sky, wo er ja heute noch ein bisschen irgendwie arbeitet, weil ich selber auch bei Premiere und Sky gearbeitet habe und ja, das hat sich dann halt irgendwann 2012 hat sich das so ergeben, dass ich hier einfach mal einmal die Woche ein bisschen gezapft habe und ja, das kommt jetzt eigentlich wieder die größere Geschichte von dir, dass Holle ja dann mich hier reingebracht hat und mir drei Monate später sagt, er hört jetzt dann hier auf. Das war dann Ende 2012, er hat dann auch aufgehört und dann stand ich hier da und habe gedacht, es ist eigentlich viel zu schade, dass der Laden jetzt irgendwie zu macht und ja, wir haben uns dann schwerst darum bemüht, das Stadion dann zu kriegen, was uns dann im Endeffekt nach langem Hin und Her auch gelungen ist, 2013 dann. Und seit 2013 bin ich dann jetzt fest an Bord.
Also das heißt, von dir das Stadion zu kriegen?
Das ist eine sehr, sehr lange Geschichte.
Ich hatte hier im Stadion wechselnde Partner.
Erst den vom Vollmond?
Genau, ich habe das mit dem vom Vollmond gemacht.
Habt ihr es damals eigentlich schon umbenannt, als du eingestiegen bist?
Ja, das haben wir komplett durchgezogen, war natürlich auch eher ein großer Aufschrei hier in der Gegend und bei vielen alten Gästen, die gesagt haben, ihr könnt doch den Vollmond nicht schließen, der Vollmond ist eine Institution. Ja, stimmt, war es für mich ja auch, aber…
Mit Institutionen verdienst du halt kein Geld.
Genau, ja, außerdem war ich oft genug der einzige Gast und hab mich halt gefragt, wo die ganzen Schreihälse sind, die sie jetzt beschweren, wo waren sie denn die letzten Jahre, um den Vollmond zu unterstützen. Und ja, wie gesagt, mit ihm habe ich das ein paar Jahre gemacht, die ersten Jahre. Dann kam noch ein weiterer dazu, da waren wir zu dritt, sehr schlechte Konstellationen, hat dann untereinander auch gar nicht mehr funktioniert. Das ist halt so dann die, vielleicht bei einem bisschen ernsteren Teil sind, die Wahrheit in der Gastronomie. Dass so was wirklich schwierig sein kann, besonders wenn man es mit Menschen macht, die man sehr mag. Und dann geht es aber am Ende doch darum, dass jeder sein Auskommen haben muss. Jeder meint, er investiert genug Zeit und der andere sieht es aber nicht so. Irgendwann war es eben so weit, dass ich praktisch als Signal was gedacht. Außerdem ging es mir in der Zeit einfach auch überhaupt nicht gut und ich habe das hier nicht mehr so ganz verpackt. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich steige aus, damit sich was bewegt, weil so wäre es auch nicht mehr weitergegangen.
Wann war das? War das zeitliche Einordnung?
Das war 2011, 2012. Dann stand der Laden irgendwann, das war die Zeit, als Michl dann schon hier gearbeitet hat, stand dann irgendwann zum Verkauf bzw. war verkauft. Irgendwelche Menschen, die so eine Cocktail-Fußball-Bar hier draus machen wollten oder die dann auch gemeint haben, oh nee, die Sachen an Wänden brauchen wir eigentlich nicht. Okay, schlussendlich war es dann so, dass wir beim Notar waren, alles war unterschrieben und ich habe mich schweren Herzens verabschiedet. Wir haben noch eine schöne Party gemacht und dann habe ich eigentlich darauf gewartet, okay, ich suche mir jetzt was Neues oder mach was anderes und jetzt bräuchte ich dann aber auch irgendwann das Geld, das die versprochen haben. Das kam aber nicht. Und hier kann Michl einsteigen.
Es war tatsächlich auch schon die Zeit, wo wir dann unabhängig vom Stadion überlegt haben, was anderes zu suchen, eine andere Location zu suchen, weil eigentlich geht es ja nicht. Ich meine, das war so eine Institution damals schon. Sie haben gesagt, das kann einfach irgendwie nicht sterben, dann gehen wir halt irgendwo anders hin und machen halt ein anderes Stadion auf. Dann heißt es halt irgendwie Stadion an der XY-Straße, völlig egal, aber Konzept war ja klar, stand ja alles, hat ja auch weitestgehend funktioniert. Die Suche nach anderen Lokalitäten ist halt in München auch irgendwie nicht ganz so einfach, auch preislich nicht. So haben wir uns schon ein paar Sachen angeguckt und haben uns auch ein paar Sachen beworben. Und das war Ende Mai, glaube ich, Ende Mai 2013 und dann war ich beim Pokalfinale Bayern gegen Stuttgart und bin auf dem Rückweg bei Leipzig, hat mein Telefon geklingelt, es hat geschüttet ohne Ende. Ich habe Holle auch erst kaum verstanden und er schreit dann irgendwann mal ins Telefon, die hätten gestern zahlen sollen, da ist aber kein Geld da, was machen wir jetzt? Ja und dann habe ich gesagt, gut, dann machen wir es halt, dann gucken wir, dass wir uns einigen mit den zwei anderen Gesellschaften und so ist es dann auch nach sehr langem Hin und Her dann auch gekommen und ja, bis das Ganze dann irgendwie auch notariell beglaubigt war und weiß Gott was alles. Ist schon ziemlich lange Zeit vergangen, aber sagen wir mal so, im Endeffekt zählt das, was am Ende rauskommt und das war dann, dass ich als Gesellschafter eingestiegen bin und wir das jetzt seit 2013 zusammen betreiben und auch damals auch alles irgendwie auf den Kopf gestellt haben. Also was heißt alles neu? Es war ja nicht alles schlecht, so ist es ja nicht. Wie gesagt, das Konzept hat ja funktioniert, aber wir haben halt so diverse Verbesserungen vorgenommen und diese haben wir eigentlich auch noch bis heute jetzt irgendwie bestanden.
Es musste professioneller werden.
Genau.
Michl fand es zum Beispiel eine gute Idee, mal eine Kasse zu haben. Nein, mussten wir nicht haben.
Mit 2, 13, das sind noch keine gebraucht. Inzwischen ist es Pflicht in der Gastronomie, aber damals gab es das noch nicht. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht irgendwie derjenige, der da die große Gastroerfahrung hat. Ich habe eigentlich mein gesamtes Studium und auch in der Zeit, teilweise danach noch, habe ich in der Gastro gearbeitet. Also und jeder, der irgendwie selber in Kneipen und Wirtshäuser geht, hat ja auch so seine Vorstellung, wie er behandelt werden will, vom Service und wie es Essen sein soll und so. Und eigentlich sind wir hier nur mit gesundem Menschenverstand rangegangen und haben halt aber auch das eine oder andere geändert. Also das fängt bei Qualität vom Essen an und geht dann halt auch bis zu, die Leute sollen nicht irgendwie zehn Minuten vor leeren Gläsern sitzen, wenn sie was trinken wollen beim Fußballspiel.
Das hört auch beim verstärkten HDMI-Kabel auf.
Oh je, diese scheiß Technik, ja. Nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Da hatte ich ja tatsächlich das Glück, weil ich ja selber auch jahrelang bei Premiere und Sky dann die letzten zwei Jahre auch gearbeitet habe und da sehr viel in der Kommunikation mit technischen Dingen zu tun hatte. Also ich kannte mich so weit, das geht irgendwie mit Sky aus, mit Fernsehtechnik und mit HDMI-Kabeln und warum funktioniert das jetzt und warum funktioniert das nicht und was muss ich da jetzt irgendwie machen. Also auch die ganze Technik haben wir halt damals erneuert und eben auch die Umstellung auf, oder hattet ihr ja schon HD? Ich weiß, das gönnt nicht mehr. Genau, haben wir dann auch auf HD einfach umgestellt, besseres Bild und einfach alles irgendwie viel geiler. Also ihr seht, von Mini-Kleinigkeiten bis zum großen Ganzen, mal unabhängig jetzt vom Konzept, Fußballkneipe, das stand ja und es hat ja wie gesagt auch funktioniert, haben wir aber trotzdem irgendwie alles irgendwie umgemodelt und ab da muss man dann auch sagen, also klar war die Unsicherheit am Anfang da, funktioniert das irgendwie alles, weil investieren mussten wir ja auch abgesehen von der Ablöse für die beiden anderen Gesellschaften mussten wir hier auch ein bisschen investieren und hat jeder ja auch so ein bisschen eigenes Geld reingesteckt und war natürlich die Unsicherheit da, funktioniert das jetzt alles so wie wir uns das vorstellen und man hat eigentlich schon relativ schnell nach drei, vier Monaten, hat man eigentlich gesehen, wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg und ja, sonst wird es uns heute auch nicht mehr geben, wenn wir nicht sehr viel richtig gemacht hätten.
Wie kam es eigentlich zum Namen? Ich kenne viele Leute, die nicht verstehen, dass es eine Kneipe ist. Wenn man sagt, wir treffen uns am Stadion an der Schleißheimer Straße, glauben die immer, das ist eine Ortsangabe.
Da gibt es auch sehr viele Lieferanten und Paketzusteller, die hier die Schleißheimer Straße auf und ab fahren und sich fragen, wo denn hier ein Stadion sein soll.
Genau aus dem Grund, also ich wollte eigentlich nur die Leute ein bisschen verarschen. Ja, wirklich so. Klar, habe ich mir gedacht, ist doch ein geiler Ausdruck, ich gehe ins Stadion. Da wird drüber geredet, ganz sicher. Das war natürlich so der Hintergedanke. Außerdem stand ich natürlich schon immer als Traditionalist auf so Namen wie Stadion an der Hamburger Straße, Stadion an der Grünwalder und so weiter, Hafenstraße. Und da lag das für mich sehr, sehr nahe.
Es hat ja auch gut funktioniert. Ihr habt ja schon gesagt, ihr habt beide auch einen beruflichen Bezug zu Sky bzw. Premiere. Du kommst auch so aus dem Sportjournalismus und du warst eher so in der Unternehmenskommunikation tätig. Hat euch das denn in irgendeiner Art und Weise auch geholfen, jetzt dabei das hier aufzuziehen? Weil ihr müsstet ja eigentlich recht viele Leute kennen. Also wenn Sky mal nicht läuft, ist doch für dich ein Anruf, Michl.
Ja, gut. Es ist jetzt auch schon tatsächlich ein bisschen her. Also ich bin im Sommer 2010 ausgestiegen bei Sky. Es gibt noch so ein paar Leute, die ich von früher halt irgendwie kennen. Gerade in der Anfangszeit war es so, dass das eine oder andere nicht so ganz funktioniert hat. Unter anderem so, du erweiterst das Abo irgendwie auf drei Abos und kriegst aber diesen Receiver nicht, den du dann unbedingt dafür brauchst, musst aber dann übermorgen irgendwie aufmachen. Und ja, da kann man dann schon mal irgendwie an gewisse Personen eine Mail schicken und dann dauert es genau eine Stunde und dann hat man einen Anruf und dann ja, wir kümmern uns darum, kommen dann morgen und so. Aber das Wesentliche, was mir hier geholfen hat, ist halt tatsächlich die ganze Technik. Das war dann, oder sagen wir mal so, ich blicke da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr durch als viele anderen. Also vor allem auch viele andere Gastronomen haben ja jetzt auch das Thema, vielleicht kommen wir da ja später noch irgendwie drauf mit Eurosport und The Zone und Internetübertragungen und wie macht man das Ganze und so. Ja, das hat schon, also das hilft dann, hilft dann schon und ja, wenn es um Leute kennen geht, gerade aus dem Sportbereich, das ist ja dann eher Holle, der in der Sportredaktion arbeitet und auch halt extrem viele Kommentatoren kennt, die dann auch mal irgendwie hier sind und das hilft natürlich auch mit bisschen prominenten Gesichtern einfach hierzu arbeiten, bringt natürlich auch was für Gäste, die dann halt auch irgendwie hier und da, den kenne ich doch aus dem Fernsehen und so.
Aber ich muss sagen, also so wirklich ausgenutzt oder so, haben wir das nicht. Natürlich ist es super, wenn man eine Veranstaltung hat, zu was weiß ich, also eine Buchlesung oder eine Diskussionsrunde, dann ist es natürlich extrem von Vorteil, wenn man einfach mal bei Marco Hagemann anrufen kann und fragen so, du hättest die Lust da mitzusprechen oder hast Lust, das zu moderieren, natürlich für ein Essen und ein Getränk.
Wir sind Uwe nicht.
Der kam aber ganz normal als Gast. Ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt, dass es natürlich was gebracht hat, da ein paar Leute zu kennen. Unter anderem wurde hier am Tisch, an dem wir jetzt sitzen, spox.com gegründet. Das sind natürlich schon immer lustige Sachen, oder wir hatten ja damals auch die die Sky-Sendung da. Das wäre natürlich auch nicht passiert, wenn mich da oder wenn uns da einfach bei Premiere damals Sky keinen Schwein kennen würde.
Könnt ihr ein bisschen ausführen, was war das für eine Sendung für diejenigen Hörer, die es nicht mitbekommen haben?
Das war die Sendung – das ist so geil, das verwechseln immer noch extrem viele, extrem viele erzählen von der 11Freunde Bayern Essen. Da wäre jetzt die Sky-Sendung – nein, die Sky-Sendung hieß Mein Stadion, was natürlich auch mit unserem Stadion zu tun hat. Donnerstag abends war das – 2011 – moderiert von Uli Potowski und dem ersten Auftritt, also sie hatte wirklich die erste Moderation hier, Ester Zetlatschek. Donnerstags live, nebenbei lief Europa League auf irgendwelchen Bildschirmen, für die Gäste haben wir gesorgt, beziehungsweise die sind einfach gern gekommen, weil es halt total locker war, weil Uli ein grandioser Typ ist, der sich auch wirklich nach jeder Sendung auch mit wirklich dem übelsten Besowski noch unterhalten hat, wobei er ja absolut kein Alkohol trinkt, also schon schwierig für ihn eigentlich, aber er hat sich hier total wohlgefühlt. Und es war natürlich schon eine extrem spannende Sache, die haben die Regie unten in unserem Keller gebaut. Keller ist so, weiß nicht, immer noch wie in den Zwanzigern.
Das heißt eigentlich für Bierfässer konzipiert.
Genau, ja für Bierfässer und sonst irgendwie Müll. Da haben die aber ihre Regie reingebaut und dann von unten aus dem Keller die Sendung gefahren. Das war schon irgendwie geil, weil Piraten Sender war. Er hat wirklich so ein bisschen was von Piraten Sender gehabt.
Eigentlich würde man den großen Ühwagen vor der Tür vermuten.
Der war auch einmal da, aber nur bei der ersten Sendung. Da hat komischerweise, glaube ich, technisch alles immer wunderbar funktioniert. Ja, und das war schon cool, aber es hat dann auch nach anderthalb Jahren gereicht. Also sowohl für Sky als auch für uns jeden Donnerstag. Das Ding war dann schon extrem anstrengend. Und Sky hat ja dann den Sendeplatz gewechselt. Die sind dann auf Freitags gegangen. Und sind dann immer zum Freitagsspiel waren die, glaube ich, noch nicht mal in der Heimspielstadt, sondern in der Auswärtsstadt anfangs. Ich weiß es nicht genau, auf jeden Fall waren sie Freitags da dann.
Auf jeden Fall immer mit Bezug zum Freitagsspiel.
Genau, aber wie Uli auch mir gegenüber immer wieder betont, das war dann nicht mehr ganz so sein Ding, weil es wurde dann eben auch schlimmer irgendwie mit den Fans und mit den wirklich Besoffenen. Er hat gemeint, die Stimmung war einfach nicht mehr so, weil hier war es halt, du hattest einen festen Laden, du kanntest alle Leute. Sogar unsere Bedienung wurde in die Sendung integriert. Shakira, wer sie noch kennt, wir warten immer noch drauf, dass irgendwann mal das Dschungelcamp anruft und Shakira will. Ja, also war schon echt eine lustige Zeit und eine interessante Zeit.
Und ja auch gute Promo, oder?
Promo war natürlich super.
Braucht man sowas als Fußballspiel?
Es gibt immer noch Leute, also ist jetzt das beste Beispiel, habe ich letzte Woche bei uns auf Facebook gepostet. Irgendeinem Fußballspiel letztens kam eine Gruppe, die eine Studienreise gemacht haben. Und irgendwann in der Halbzeit kommt ein junger Typ zu mir, das wird so 18, 19 sein, und zeigt mir ein Foto von der Sendung damals und sagt, das bin übrigens ich. Und das war ein ganz, da war er ein kleiner Junge. Und war eben damals mit seinen Eltern, waren sie in München und er wollte eben unbedingt in diese Sendung, haben die Eltern ihm erlaubt und waren dann mit ihm zusammen da. Dann hat er auch ein Foto mit mir gemacht. Ich war damals total prominent, ich war eigentlich auch auf das Dschungelcamp noch. Und jetzt nach sechs Jahren, sieben Jahren kommt er an und sagt, ich bin wieder da. Also wirklich. Sowas sind Geschichten, die…
Die treifen nur die Fußballkarten.
Genau, die sind einfach wunderbar.
Ja, aber promo-mäßig hat es sicherlich was gebracht. Also das ist ja keine Frage.
Das war ja auch kurz vor der schweren Zeit dann, oder? So, wenn man sagt 2011.
Ja, genau. Also das ging da mit rein, dass es dann auch irgendwann zu viel wurde. Ich hatte ja da auch irgendwie meine Auftritte, das war aber auch nicht so mein Ding vor der Kamera dann. Also für mich selber irgendwie nicht wirklich funktioniert und so. War damals alles einfach nicht so einfach.
Dabei gibt es auch noch legendäre Videos auf YouTube zu finden.
Gibt es noch?
Ja, unter anderem den Piloten, der leider nie weiterverfolgt wurde. Das Video-Podcast mit Fox. Liebe Kollegen von mir in ganz, ganz jungen Jahren.
Das stimmt, ja, das stimmt.
Das gucke ich mir immer mal wieder an, einfach um Dinge in der Hinterhand zu haben. Weil man es braucht. Wie hat sich das denn verändert? Also 2006 Fußballkneipe in München gegründet. Das fällt so ein bisschen gleich bei mir mit Studienbeginn und ich habe das damals so erlebt, als hätte es so einen richtigen Hype gegeben, dass überall Fußballkneipen sich gegründet haben. Ich habe es halt in Freiburg erlebt und in Würzburg so noch ein bisschen am Rand. Aber das ist natürlich auch selektive Wahrnehmung, wie hat sich das verändert jetzt über die Jahre?
Also das ist vielleicht gar keine selektive Wahrnehmung, weil es tatsächlich irgendwie – 2004, 2005 hat Sky – nee, damals noch Premiere, Entschuldigung – hat ja angefangen, mit wirklich offensiv Gastro-Abos zu vertreiben und das jetzt, ja jetzt Fußballkneipe war ja damals noch nicht wirklich so irgendwie ein Ausdruck, sondern mein Gott, es gab halt irgendwie – Es gab nicht so wirklich, ne? Es gab nicht so wirklich eigentlich.
Das war ja auch der Grund, also das war die Idee, wie ich draufgekommen bin. Ich hatte während der WM26 das Follow-Your-Team-Ticket Serbien-Monte-Negro geschossen. Das heißt, ich hatte Tickets bis zum Finale und war eben dementsprechend in der Republik unterwegs und – Serbien-Monte-Negro war im Finale? Das habe ich irgendwie verpasst.
Ja, wir haben ja vorhin schon über deine Erinnerungslücke gesprochen.
Und in jeder Stadt, in der ich war, irgendwie Leipzig, auch Berlin, haben wir halt gedacht, da muss es doch Fußballkneipen geben. Also so einfach Fußballkneipen. Und gab es aber nirgends, haben wir nirgends gefunden. Und dann haben wir eben angefangen, so ein Kumpel und ich, da auf den Zugfahrten ein bisschen rumzuspinnen und hatten schon diese Geschichten mit, da muss mal Kunstrasen an die Decke machen, Tribüne muss da reingebaut werden, das muss total krank sein, das wäre schön. Und wir gucken nach oben und sehen Kunstrasen an der Decke und wir gucken nach hinten und sehen eine Tribüne. Ich hatte damals doch den Gedanken, es gibt es bestimmt schon irgendwo, irgendjemand hat das schon gemacht, aber es gibt es nicht.
Es waren halt einfach ganz normale Kneipen oder Gaststätten, die dann einfach ein Premiere-Abo hatten, die dann halt, meistens ging es halt darum, ihren lokalen Verein dann irgendwie zu zeigen, die Auswärtsspiele oder auch Heimspiele, je nachdem, und vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen Konferenz oder sowas, wenn der Heimatverein nicht gespielt hat. Aber als Fußballkneipe, wie gesagt, Premiere hat dann immer mit den Sports-Bars da irgendwie versucht, mit dem Sports-Bar-Ausdruck, den man ja aus den USA halt vor allem irgendwie kennt, da irgendwie zu operieren, aber ja, da gab es dann halt irgendwie schöne Schilder und Aufkleber und weiß Gott was alles irgendwie Premiere-Sports-Bar. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine Fußballkneipe, also wir brauchen ja gar nicht von jetzt hier reden, wie es hier aussieht, aber dass da mal irgendwie vielleicht zwei Trikots an der Wand hingen oder sowas, das kam schon mal vor, aber im Großen und Ganzen waren das stinknormale Kneipen und Gaststätten, die halt dann einfach ein Premiere-Abo hatten und da halt noch ab und zu mal, wenn es interessant war, einfach Fußball gezeigt haben. Aber so reine Fußballkneipe, so wie wir es jetzt irgendwie haben, gab es damals einfach noch gar nicht.
Ich glaube, damals war das auch noch die Zeit, in der dieses Thema – wir kommen ja danach noch mal drauf – Lizenzgebühren und so, da war das noch relativ harmlos, d.h. da konnte eine Kneipe auch mal so nebenbei so ein damals Premiere-Abo haben für Gastro, ohne dass sie gleich in richtige Finanzierung schwere Geschäfte hat.
Ja, wobei ist damals – also das weiß ich jetzt noch aus meiner Zeit in der Unternehmenskommunikation – hatte ich da ja auch schon immer mal wieder irgendwie damit zu tun, dass ja halt Wirte angerufen haben oder eine Mail geschrieben haben und gesagt haben, oh, das ist aber so teuer. Also im Vergleich zu heute ist es ehrlich gesagt ein Witz, was es damals gekostet hat. Aber da war auch schon die Refinanzierungsschwierigkeit einfach da ganz anders wie heute. Also heute ist es einfach irgendwie viel schlimmer und das merkt man ja auch, weil du jetzt gefragt hast irgendwie nach der Entwicklung. Also jetzt schon allein in der Zeit, in der ich jetzt hier bin im Stadion hatten wir halt schon mehrere Preiserhöhungen und du merkst es einfach, dass gerade normale Kneipen einfach dann gesagt haben, okay, wir haben 100 Quadratmeter, wir müssten jetzt Betrag XY zahlen, wie soll ich das refinanzieren mit vier Bayern-Spielen im Monat oder lass es mit Champions League dann mal sechs sein oder sowas. Und du zahlst ja die Abo-Gebühr auch in Zeiten, wo kein Fußball ist, im Sommer zum Beispiel. Da hat sich schon einiges irgendwie geändert und wir merken, dass ja auch hier, wenn wir halt dann irgendwie rappelvoll sind und den Leuten dann halt an der Tür erklären müssen, wo ist denn dann die nächste Sports Bar, so Eichfield gibt es jetzt hier in der Gegend nicht und es ist halt dann auch immer irgendwie weniger geworden. Und jetzt gerade hier für München, wenn ich das irgendwie mitkriege, Leopoldstraße, hast du einen 300-Quadratmeter-Laden und zeigst irgendwie ab und zu mal irgendwie die Bayern, das kannst du einfach fast nicht mehr refinanzieren. Beziehungsweise ist dann einfach eine Quersubventionierung. Und ob sich das halt dann lohnt für einen großen Laden vielleicht noch oder könnte es vielleicht sein, aber jetzt irgendwie für die Eckkneipe, die keine Ahnung in Giesingen jetzt bisher immer die Sechziger gezeigt hat und sonst eigentlich nichts, wird es dann halt schon echt schwierig. Und das ist ja der Unterschied halt zu unserem Konzept, dass wir halt wirklich alles irgendwie, was an Fußball geht, dann auch irgendwie zeigen. Und nur so kannst du es refinanzieren, obwohl es für uns dann halt auch schon immer irgendwie die Schwierigkeit ist, wenn es dann wieder eine Preiserhöhung gibt und wenn es nur irgendwie eine kleine Preiserhöhung gibt, dann halt zu überlegen, okay, was machen wir, erhöhen wir jetzt mit die Preise, Getränkepreise oder Essenspreise. Meistens machen wir das erst mit einem Jahr Verzögerung dann nach einer Preiserhöhung. Aber es ist halt nun mal so, wir müssen halt beide auch davon leben, auch wenn Holle noch ein bisschen nebenher dann bei Sky arbeitet und sonstige Projekte irgendwie in seinem eigentlichen Job macht. Aber ich lebe zu 100 Prozent davon und Holle auch zu einem guten Teil. Und da muss halt am Ende auch was bei rumkommen. Also es ist jetzt tatsächlich mal die Ironie beiseite geschoben. Es ist zumindest ein Fulltime-Job und du bist 24-7 eigentlich eher mit dem Laden beschäftigt. Das geht auch nicht anders, weil es ist halt tatsächlich nicht so, dass wir irgendwie mittags um eins irgendwann mal aufstehen und In unserem Geld schwimmen. In unserem Geld ein bisschen schwimmen, genau. Und dann abends den Laden aufschließen und ein bisschen Spaß haben. So ist es dann doch nicht. Aber das soll jetzt kein Gejammer sein, das macht dir auch wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Und man sieht ja auch, also das Feedback von den Gästen ist halt dann auch immer überwältigend. Und das pusht einen ja dann auch immer wieder. Oder wie wir es ja auch jetzt gerade im Vorspann gehört haben, Rasenfunk, das ist ja, wenn da ein Kali sowas erzählt oder ein Frank Gosen, das ist halt einfach schon auch schön, sowas zu hören.
Wenn du jetzt schon diesen Rückgriff auf den Vorspann machst, dann muss ich natürlich fragen, gibt es denn das Schnitzelkali mittlerweile?
Und es ist auch wirklich riesig. Wer glaubt, Frank Gosen hätte übertrieben oder Rainer Kallmund hätte übertrieben? Nein, nein.
Rainer Kallmund übertreibt sowieso nie.
Ja, aber ich finde, jetzt haben wir schon ganz spannenden Punkt angesprochen, nämlich wie sich das auch verändert hat für Fußballkneipen mit Sky und den Abos. Und ich kann mich erinnern, zumindest eine der Preiserhöhungen, die es da gab, die hatte auch richtig ein mediales Echo, weil da viele Kneipen zugemacht haben, auch hier in München. Und ich habe damals mitbekommen, in Freiburg, wo ich studiert habe, haben damals auch viele zugemacht. Könnt ihr mal kurz erklären, wie sich überhaupt Sky Abos für euch berechnen? Also sind ja nicht die, bei mir ist es so, ich kündige und warte dann so lange, bis sie mir ein halbwegs vernünftiges Angebot machen. Und dann zahle ich halt 32 Euro im Monat.
Vielleicht als Erstes ist es mal so, auch wenn wir beide bei Sky gearbeitet haben und vielleicht mal schneller einen Support kriegen. Kohlemäßig ist uns da noch nie jemand entgegengekommen. Also wir zahlen den ganz normalen Preis. Das muss man vielleicht auch mal feststellen bei den ganzen Medienkontakten, bla bla bla. Sky hat das Jahr vor zwei Jahren nochmal alles neu gemacht. Davor waren es ja nur die Quadratmeter. Jetzt geht es um Kaufkraft der Stadt, der Gegend sogar, Einwohnerzahl, Anzahl der Bundesligisten und Zweitligisten in der Stadt und so weiter. Also ein ganz komischer, extrem intransparenter Schlüssel.
Auch so, dass man sich selber nicht mal ausrechnen kann, oder?
Ja, es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen Absicht, dass man das nicht untereinander in der Republik vergleichen kann. Also dass man zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie in Regensburg oder so was, sage ich jetzt mal, zahle ich aber so und so viel und ich habe die gleiche Quadratmeteranzahl. Du kannst das halt dann irgendwie nicht vergleichen, auch wenn wir irgendwie gefragt werden, was wir zahlen. Also wir halten uns ja da eher irgendwie zurück mit Zahlen. Geht ja im Grunde auch irgendwie niemanden was an. Aber man könnte die Zahl jetzt auch nicht mit irgendeinem anderen Ort, selbst teilweise in München, kann man das nicht wirklich irgendwie vergleichen. Weil ich meine, hier in der Max-Vorstadt ist es nun mal so, dass es eine der bevölkerungsreichsten Gegenden ist und München ja auch eine extrem hohe Kaufkraft hat. Also sind wir eigentlich eh schon von daher für unsere Quadratmeterzahl am oberen Limit. Es ist halt tatsächlich auch so, dass sich das dann immer wieder irgendwie finanziell auswirkt durch Preiserhöhungen, wobei man tatsächlich auch sagen muss, die Preiserhöhung in diesem Jahr war sehr, sehr, sehr moderat.
Dafür haben wir ja jetzt auch zwei Jahre den festen Preis und wissen dann seit letzter Woche auch, dass wir keine Europa League mehr über Sky sehen können.
Ja, das sind halt so die üblichen Geschichten. Ich meine, die kenne ich ja auch noch aus meiner Vergangenheit. Dann fallen halt irgendwie Rechte weg. Und so geht es ja auch einem Privatabonnenten. Da fallen Rechte weg. Ja, dann müsste es ja eigentlich irgendwie günstiger werden. Also wir verstehen natürlich einerseits auch, dass Sky jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Prozent mehr für die Bundesliga Rechte zahlt. Also das sind ja einfach auch ganz komische Spiralen, die sich die DFL vielleicht auch mal überlegen sollte, die da ja dann irgendwelche Jubelmeldungen rausbringen, wie viel sie jetzt irgendwie für die Verein, natürlich nur für die Vereine, eingenommen haben. Aber das muss halt auch jemand zahlen. Und im Endeffekt ist es der Fußballfan, der es irgendwie zahlen muss. Weil wenn wir mehr zahlen, müssen wir halt auch wieder gucken, dass wir es irgendwie refinanzieren können, müssen dann Preise erhöhen. Das heißt, es wird dann für unsere Gäste wieder teurer. Für einen Privatabonnenten ist es halt im Normalfall auch so. Okay, die zahlen jetzt mehr, dann muss ich irgendwie auch mehr zahlen. Andererseits, die Spirale in die andere Richtung gibt es zum Beispiel nicht, wenn irgendwelche Rechte wegfallen. Und da ist ja bei Sky und auch schon zu Premierezeiten sind ja schon immer wieder viele Rechte weggefallen, auch, weil wir jetzt gerade gesagt haben, dass es beim Gastro-Abo auch darauf ankommt, wie viele Bundesligisten und Zweitligisten jetzt in der Gegend irgendwie sind. Also wir haben jetzt nichts gemerkt durch den Zwangsabstieg von 60, dass unser Abo irgendwie günstiger geworden ist. Und man muss tatsächlich, auch wenn wir jetzt nicht in Giesing, sondern in der Max-Vorstadt sind, man muss tatsächlich schon auch sagen, das sind Umsatzeinbußen für uns, dass 60 jetzt in der Regionalliga spielt. Das macht schon extrem viel einfach aus.
Krass. Das würde mich interessieren, wie der Erfolg eures Ladens an den sportlichen Erfolg verschiedener Vereine und des internationalen Wettbewerbs gekoppelt ist. Aber um dieses Thema, wie ist Sky für Gastronomen, abzuschließen, könnte da so eine ganz grobe Großenordnung gehen. Reden wir über da mehrere hundert Euro im Monat oder sind das mehrere tausend Euro? Aber nur so ein grobes Gefühl, wie teuer ist das?
Sagen wir mal so, im Jahr ist es ein fünfstelliger Bereich, eine fünfstellige Zahl.
Man muss aber noch dazu sagen, ich glaube, das wissen wahrscheinlich auch viele gar nicht, dass man ja eben seit zwei Jahren auch zwei Abos zusätzlich kriegt dazu, wenn man eins abschließt.
Du kriegst zwei Karten, also du schließt ein Abo ab und kriegst drei Karten und drei Receivers, sodass du tatsächlich drei verschiedene Spiele zeigen kannst.
Was wir eben auch ausnutzen bzw. ausnutzen können, was aber für einen Wirt von der Eckkneipe vollkommen wurscht ist, weil der hat nur einen Bildschirm und will auch nur dieses eine Spiel zeigen, kriegt es wahrscheinlich, unterstelle ich jetzt mal technisch auch nicht hin, weil es einfach auch kompliziert ist mit einem HDMI-Switch.
Ja, richtig.
Meint ihr, das ist gewollt von so rechten Inhabern wie Sky? Oder es gibt jetzt ja auch noch einige andere Player. Wollen die, dass es, wenn es Kneipen gibt, dann nur dezidierte Fußballkneipen gibt und die Borzen um die Ecke Fußball gar nicht mehr zeigt?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie das nicht wollen.
Sie wollen ja Privatkunden, und die gehen ja auch hoch.
Ja, aber so darf man das jetzt nicht wirklich irgendwie sehen, dass je mehr Gastro-Abo es gibt, gibt es dann gleichzeitig weniger Privat-Abos. Also Fußball schauen in der Kneipe ist halt auch ein Gemeinschaftserlebnis. Da treffe ich mich irgendwie mit Freunden. Okay, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie nicht einsehe, ein Sky-Abo abzuschließen, dann bin ich aber jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so der wahnsinnig große Fußballfan und gucke mir halt ab und zu mal irgendwie ein Spiel, wenn mein Verein spielt oder sowas. Und wir zeigen das dann irgendwie zufällig. Also wir reden ja jetzt nicht irgendwie vom FC Bayern hier in der Stadt, sondern wir zeigen ja alles Mögliche. Und hier kann ja auch jeder mit auch ein bisschen Glück. Und wenn es ein paar Reservierungen gibt, zeigen wir dann auch irgendwie samstags 15.30 Uhr parallel zur Konferenz und zu den Bayern dann von mir aus Dortmund oder Lasses Frankfurt oder Freiburg sein. Also wir versuchen das ja schon alles irgendwie möglich zu machen. Aber um aufs Eigentliche jetzt zurückzukommen, es ist natürlich schon so, dass du in eine Kneipe gehst mit Freunden. Weil wenn ich zu Hause ein Abo habe, okay, kann ich mal machen, dass dann mal ein paar Kumpels zu mir kommen und wir gucken dann ein bisschen Fußball mit einer Kiste Bier oder sowas. Aber das Eigentliche ist halt, in eine Fußballkneipe zu gehen mit Freunden, das Gemeinschaftserlebnis zu haben, ein bisschen Bier zu trinken, ein bisschen Spaß zu haben. Vielleicht, es sind auch, im Übrigen muss man auch dazu sagen, sehr viele unserer Gäste haben zu Haus ein SkyAbo.
Aber glaubst du nicht, umgekehrt, diese Preisstrukturänderung, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, hat ja durchaus dazu geführt, dass ein Haufen kleine Kneipen gesagt haben, okay, das geht nicht mehr für mich. Das so, ich sag jetzt mal, nicht jetzt in München, aber im ländlicheren Bereich, wo es in Ortschaften, keine Ahnung, die Größe 5.000 bis 10.000 Einwohner sollen, in denen ich wohne, wo einige Kneipen dieser Art Zug gemacht haben, dass für die Leute, die da bisher hingegangen sind, weil sie gesagt haben, so soll ich mir ein Sky-Abo holen, die vier Bayern-Spiele im Monat oder drei, da geh ich halt in die Kneipe.
Dass das potenzielle Kunden sind.
Dass das jetzt potenzielle Kunden sind, weil die eben, die brauchen vielleicht nur das Bundesliga-Abo, das kostet die verhältnismäßig weniger als Privatkunden und die haben einfach nichts mehr, wo sie hingehen. Ich glaube, damit kalkuliert Sky schon.
Aber wenn du, Max hat ja von den anderen Playern gesprochen. Die Player sind ja jetzt Perform, also The Zone, Eurosport. Ich meine, allein an den beiden siehst du, ich behaupte es einfach mal, dass die an die Gastronomie erst mal überhaupt gar nicht gedacht haben.
Haben die Gastroavos eigentlich?
Noch nicht.
Das heißt, rein theoretisch dürfte man da nichts zeigen, oder ist es dann quasi ein…
Geduldet. Okay.
Wir haben das Zone damals angeschrieben. Sehr am Anfang noch. Und dann ist erstmal da die juristische Abteilung ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen, weil die da wirklich einfach nicht dran gedacht haben. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, ihr dürft es zeigen, beziehungsweise sind dann auch auf den Trichter gekommen. Pass mal auf, eigentlich ist es ja sogar eine super Werbung. Daran sollte Sky vielleicht auch mal denken, dass es keine bessere Werbung gibt als eine Fußballkneipe, wo du das Produkt einfach siehst. Und zwar einen ganzen Abend.
Und es soll auch aus, dass man die Vorberichterstattung nicht hören kann.
Also auch wirklich perfekt. Auf an, was man für ein Produkt anbietet.
Ja, genau.
Ja, aber es ist ja perfekt.
Man hört ja von der Vorberichterstattung immer.
Ja, aber wie ändert sich das jetzt dann? Also ihr müsst ja jetzt auf einmal streamen.
Alter, das springt mir jetzt schon zum nächsten Thema.
Ja, naja, es sind halt gerade so die, die, der Umbruch, oder?
Also man muss jetzt, man muss jetzt sagen, ähm, äh, Eurosport läuft jetzt stabil, nachdem wir am ersten Spieltag äh, die erste Halbzeit nicht gesehen haben, äh, am zweiten Spiel, da gab's auch nochmal einen Ausfall. Inzwischen läuft das, ähm.
Ohne Aussetzer.
Ohne Aussetzer. Ähm, meiner Meinung nach.
Bildqualität lässt extrem zu wünschen.
Von der Bildqualität, ähm, ganz schwach. Wirklich ganz schwach. Ähm, inhaltlich dafür gut.
Ja.
Wirklich gut.
Also da hatten wir, bei Eurosport hatten wir tatsächlich das Gefühl, es geht endlich mal wieder um Fußball. Und zwar nur um Fußball. Wenn ich Jan Henkel und Matthias Sammer sehe, das ist einfach sehr fundiert. Das ist kein Boulevard-Gelaber oder sonst irgendwie was. Da geht es nicht um die Frau von oder sonst irgendwie was. Da hören sie auch mal zu. Also das ist eine sehr, sehr gute Berichterstattung, was die machen. Also handwerklich einfach überragend. Ähm, wenn die jetzt tatsächlich noch daran arbeiten, dass es eine bessere Bildqualität gibt, dann gibt es da eigentlich nichts mehr auszusetzen, muss man echt sagen. Was du jetzt aber gerade angesprochen hast, mit Streaming und wir werden, also nicht nur wir, sondern vor allem ganz viele, ganz viele Kneipen, die Fußball zeigen, ob jetzt mit Sky oder sonst irgendwie oder ohne. Wir werden ja nächstes Jahr das große Problem haben dann mit The Zone, die die Champions League und die Euro League sogar exklusiv übertragen. Ich meine, noch ist noch nicht irgendwie klar, wie die Champions League-Rechte jetzt aufgeteilt sind. Wer da was überträgt, was Sky überträgt, was The Zone überträgt. Das wird nochmal eine große Herausforderung sein. Also sagen wir mal so, jetzt für uns das Streaming zu übertragen, ist ja inzwischen völlig easy für uns. Also es sind teilweise auch unsere Mitarbeiter, was sie machen müssen, wenn wir mal irgendwie nicht da sind. Aber das große Problem wird halt irgendwie sein, wer überträgt was, weil nur als kleine Geschichte, wenn man die Konferenz von Sky überträgt, und parallel dazu jetzt ein Einzelspiel, was zur Konferenz dazugehört, da habe ich halt beim Streaming einfach einen Versatz von wahrscheinlich einer Minute, vielleicht sind es auch zwei Minuten. Das hängt dann auch so ganz da vom Buffering wieder ab. Aber da kann es halt nicht sein, da sehe ich halt das Tor in der Konferenz und in meinem Einzelspiel, was ich dann parallel irgendwie gucke, kommt das Tor dann halt irgendwie eine Minute oder zwei Minuten später. Also es ist ein absolutes No-Go. Da müssen wir uns tatsächlich auch noch irgendwie überlegen, wie wir das machen.
Konferenz in der Champions League auch niemand sehen, ist so, weil wir haben ja die zwei Bildschirme, um die Spiele parallel laufen zu lassen. Außerdem reservieren die Leute natürlich für das Hauptspiel. Also wenn Bayern spielt, ist es eh keine Diskussion, will jeder sehen. Dortmund in der Champions League allerdings auch, und Leipzig halt tendenziell eher nicht.
Ja, wer weiß, wer nächstes Jahr ist in der Champions League.
Aber wo wir bei dem Streaming sind, Thema letztens Bayern, Freitagabend, das erste Mal bei Eurosport Streaming. Ein paar Tage vorher stand eine Wirtin, wo wir auch immer, die hier in der Gegend ist, wo wir auch immer gerne Leute hinschicken, wenn bei uns voll ist. Und hat eben gefragt, und genau so was haben wir, so denken wir das uns in ganz normalen Kneipen. Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt auf einen Bildschirm aus dem Internet? Also ich habe da was abgeschlossen, habe jetzt den Player, aber wie mache ich denn das? Und das sind die wirklich ganz einfachen und schwierigen Fragen. Wie kriege ich das hin? Wie kriege ich denn das dann hin? Also überlegen wir auch noch, dass wir dann vielleicht zwei Einzelspiele über der Zone zeigen können. Was brauchen wir da wiederum? Können wir da umschalten?
Ja, das muss man ja auch die Internetleitung zur Verfügung haben. Also hier in München kriegt man das ja gerade noch hin.
Genau, aber das ist richtig.
Aber naja, die neue Bundesregierung wird ja wieder eine digitale Initiative starten wie vor vier Jahren auch schon und die wird wahrscheinlich auch wahnsinnig viel bringen. Wir haben tatsächlich das Glück in München, dass man es relativ gut auswählen kann. Und ja, ich meine, die Empfehlung ist ja immer mindestens eine 10 MBit-Leitung. Je höher, desto besser. Also ich glaube, wir haben eine 50 MBit-Leitung und wir schaffen es tatsächlich zwei Spiele von der Zone parallel zum Stream laufen zu lassen und die Bildqualität ist gut. Also, könnte natürlich immer irgendwie besser sein, aber wenn ich das jetzt vergleiche, der Zone und Eurosport ist ein himmelweiter Unterschied. Also das ist praktisch wie Eurosport, wie Analogfernsehen und der Zone dann tatsächlich annähernd HD, kann man schon so sagen.
Eurosport ist es wahrscheinlich halt in Zugeständnis an die ersten beiden Spieltage, an die Probleme, weil da war die Qualität tatsächlich ganz okay, wenn es mal lief.
Ja, andererseits muss man da halt dann irgendwie jetzt als Nutzer, was wir ja nun mal irgendwie sind, und wir uns da ein bisschen irgendwie auskennen, aus meiner Sicht ist es einfach nur eine Kapazitätsfrage, eine Serverkapazitätsfrage. Und wenn ich jetzt halt einfach mal sage, ich habe keine Ahnung, 100.000 Abonnenten, dann muss ich halt einfach auch für 100.000 Abonnenten die Serverkapazität zur Verfügung stellen, auch wenn vielleicht nur 20.000 zugreifen, aber ich muss davon ausgehen, dass 100.000 da drauf zugreifen. Das selbe Problem hatte ja letztes Jahr der Sauen, als die gestartet sind. Gut, die erzählen immer irgendwie was anderes. Genau. Aus meiner Sicht ist es einfach so damals, Manchester Derby ist das erste große Spiel, das sie übertragen hatten. Wir hatten hier, glaube ich, so ungefähr 80 Leute, 80 Prozent Engländer, die dann halt erst mal überhaupt gar nicht verstanden haben, warum kommt da jetzt irgendwie nichts. Da kannst du denen auch noch irgendwie erklären, was das da jetzt irgendwie ist. Die kennen das halt aus England, mit British Telecom, da funktioniert das halt einfach. Und bei uns funktioniert es halt nicht. Also dann war dann immer so, ist doch euer Problem? Nee, ist ein Problem von denen. Und der Sauen hat daraus auch gelernt. Das funktioniert, wie gesagt, sehr gut. Bei Eurosport bin ich da ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuscht. Man weiß ja schon länger irgendwie, dass man die Rechte hat. Und dann halt so ein Desaster am ersten Spieltag und eigentlich auch die Folgen.
Mit einem riesen Konzern dahinter.
Mit einem riesen Konzern dahinter, das darf man ja auch nicht irgendwie vergessen.
Vielleicht ist das das Problem. Ich habe immer den Eindruck, die Bundesliga ist gar nicht wichtig genug für den Eurosport-Player, sondern man weiß ja, dass die Olympischen Spiele das große Ding werden. Und wenn ich mir so einfach nur die Aufmachung anschaue und wie auch die Kommunikation lief, dann habe ich manchmal so den Eindruck, die haben das mitgenommen, weil es war da, aber im Fokus stand es nicht, also vom Konzern her gesprochen. Da wäre eine kleinere Butze, die nur die Bundesliga-Rechte hätte, die wäre mehr dahinter.
Also wenn der Sonn das gekauft hätte... Ja, aber gut, ich muss halt schon irgendwie überlegen, wenn ich diese Rechte irgendwie kaufe. Und du sprichst das zwar jetzt an mit den Olympischen Spielen, natürlich ist das irgendwie eine große Nummer mit den Olympischen Spielen, aber die Olympischen Spiele gehen zwei Wochen, alle zwei Jahre Sommer-Winter. Die Bundesliga geht halt irgendwie über, wie viele Spiele werden es dann insgesamt sein, was Eurosport 42, glaube ich, Bundesliga-Spiele, das geht halt auch über das ganze Jahr. Und ich glaube auch übers Jahr gesehen hat Eurosport mit der Bundesliga erreicht da wesentlich mehr Zuschauer als in den zwei Wochen Olympische Spiele. Da erreicht man dann vielleicht irgendwie den Otto Normalbürger, den sogenannten, aber die Masse an Fußballfans, die man auch noch damit irgendwie vergrault. Zumal – gut, wir stehen jetzt nicht am Anfang, also manchmal könnte man meinen, wir sind im Jahr 2005 mit den ersten Live-Streamings. Aber man vergrault auch eben mit dieser neuen Übertragungsmöglichkeit, gerade mit der Bundesliga auch sehr viele – wie sagt man da jetzt – User, Nutzer im Internet? Keine Ahnung, also Zuschauer einfach. Ich habe die Anfänge mitgemacht bei Premiere mit Streaming. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass sich das dann zehn oder zwölf Jahre später genauso wiederholt und dass die gleichen Fehler gemacht werden wie zehn Jahre davor. Das ist eigentlich schon ein bisschen erstaunlich. Aber wie gesagt, durch den neuen Übertragungsweg kann man sich auch den einen oder anderen damit verkraulen, die eh schon dann sagen, was soll das jetzt und warum brauche ich jetzt noch ein Abo und warum übers Internet. Und hätten wir es sicherlich alles irgendwie besser machen können.
Thema Technik, ich kenne das ja vom Rasenfunk. Im Grunde seit Folge eins an, Frank, optimieren wir die Technik und haben da jetzt auch weder Kosten noch Mühen gesteuert. Das kann man inzwischen jetzt auch ganz gut nachvollziehen, auch an dem, was hier alles auf dem Tisch steht. Und trotzdem ist es so, du nimmst mit einem Gast auf, dem hast du vorher das Headset noch geschickt. Du hast einen Techniktest gemacht, einen Audio-Test. Alles läuft wunderbar und dann fängt irgendjemand in seiner Nachbarschaft an, keine Ahnung. YouTube zu streamen oder Telekom hat mal wieder Probleme oder welchen Kabelbetreiber auch immer er hat. Das heißt, es gibt immer noch Folgen, bei denen es dann trotz aller Vorbereitung immer noch Probleme gibt, die dann, glaube ich, auch manchmal kann man dann im Nachhinein noch was kaschieren. Aber wo ich auch merke, das ist einfach so ein Glücksspiel. Manchmal haut es auch einfach nicht hin. Wie ist denn das jetzt im Bezug auf Streaming und checken das vor allem eigentlich die Leute, die hier sitzen? Weil ihr könnt da ja auch nichts dran ändern, wenn mal – also Stromausfall würde jetzt noch jeder erkennen, aber wenn einfach hier das Internet schlecht ist, das gibt es ja.
Also Stromausfall hatten wir tatsächlich auch schon. Das liegt dann an unserem alten Haus mit den Sicherungen. Wenn dann plötzlich auch das Kabelfernsehen nicht mehr funktioniert, sprich Sky nicht mehr funktioniert, da fallen dann nicht die Receiver aus, sondern da fällt dann die komplette Anlage aus. Licht brennt aber. Und dann erstmal jeder so, oh was ist jetzt los? Und dann erstmal immer so, scheiß Sky. Das ist dann immer gleich so die erste Reaktion, was haben die jetzt wieder irgendwie gemacht? Als mir das das erste Mal passiert ist, hat es tatsächlich auch irgendwie zehn Minuten gedauert, bis ich drauf gekommen bin, dass vielleicht die Sicherung rausgehauen hat. Seitdem ist es noch zweimal passiert, aber dann geht es relativ schnell, weil ich weiß, wo die Sicherung ist und dann macht man die ganz schnell wieder irgendwie rein und dann läuft das auch brutal schnell wieder. Also das ist echt erstaunlich.
Starten eure Sky Receiver keine drei Minuten? Bei mir würde das erstmal drei Minuten dauern.
Das finde ich tatsächlich das Erstaunliche. Beziehungsweise es liegt nicht an den Sky Receiver, weil die weiterhin Strom haben, sondern die Verteilstation des Kabelfernsehens vom Haus fällt dann einfach aus. Das heißt, die Receiver sind an, aber ich mache dann die Sicherung an und dann kommt aber gleich wieder Signal. Das geht relativ schnell. Solche Probleme gibt es dann tatsächlich auch immer wieder. Aber mit Streaming, ich würde mal sagen, viele, gerade jetzt Freitagabends, die wissen, es läuft über den Player. Die sind teilweise auch genau deswegen da, weil ihre Kneipe das jetzt irgendwie nicht zeigt und die wissen, dass wir dann das Freitagabends-Spiel über den Player zeigen.
Bei Eurosport Gate, nenne ich es mal, am ersten Spieltag gab es tatsächlich zwei Mädels, die nicht nur mich, sondern auch sämtliche Bedienungen alle paar Minuten angeschissen haben. Aber wir haben doch reserviert für das Spiel. Wir wollen doch das Spiel jetzt sehen. Ja, aber es funktioniert gerade nicht. Aber wir haben doch reserviert. Ruhig bleiben. Wirklich ruhig bleiben. Da habe ich dann nicht nur fünf Zigaretten in der Halbzeit geraucht, sondern neun.
War ja auch eine längere Halbzeit.
Ja, war auch eine längere Halbzeit. Ja, da muss man dann schon ruhig bleiben. Ansonsten, wirklich die meisten verstehen das, kennen das ja auch von Zuhause, von Youporn und so. Und von daher ist es okay. Und es kommen tatsächlich, also die Schalker waren jetzt da. Die Iser Schalker, das ist ein ganz berühmter Fanclub, weil es eben in ihrer Stammkneipe, die zeigen Eurosport eben nicht. Wahrscheinlich aus genau dem Grund, dass sie nicht wissen, wie man es installiert oder wie man das macht.
Ist es dann für euch vielleicht dann sogar ganz gut, dass das immer mehr zerstückelt wird? Also ich habe jetzt schon häufiger von Leuten gelesen, jetzt muss ich noch ein drittes Abo abschließen, um alles sehen zu können, da habe ich keine Lust drauf. Glaubt ihr, dass die Leute dann so für Freitagsspiele mal hierher kommen?
Ja, das kommt. Also da habe ich jetzt zumindest einen Eindruck, dass wir schon Gäste hier haben, die sonst noch nicht so oft da waren, die uns da kennen, aber das wird sich sicherlich auch widerlegen. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, ob das jetzt ein Vorteil für uns ist, irgendwie mit der Zerstückelung, dass es halt viele andere nicht zeigen oder man es zu Hause nicht gucken kann oder sonst irgendwie was. Das Problem ist halt, wenn hier voll ist, ist es halt voll. Und dann haben wir halt auch irgendwie nichts davon. Also ich habe auch nichts davon, wenn FC Bayern exklusiv bei Sky kommt, bringt uns nichts, weil voll ist einfach voll und mehr kriegen wir dann halt nicht rein. Bei uns ist es tatsächlich, und deswegen habe ich das ja vorhin auch gesagt, mit dem gemeinschaftlichen Fußballschauen, ob das ZDF jetzt das Bayernspiel überträgt oder nicht, macht für uns eigentlich nichts aus. Also Bayernspiele, Champions League, kriegen wir alle mal voll. Genauso auch Dortmund-Spiele. Es gibt halt einfach eine große Fangemeinde hier. Was ja auch unser Vorteil ist hier in München mit den vielen Zugreisten, dass jeder eigentlich dann auch seinen Lieblingsverein logischerweise mitbringt und nicht automatisch Bayernfan wird zum Glück. Und wir halt versuchen, so viel wie möglich zu zeigen. Also wo kannst du irgendwie ein Freiburgspiel in München schauen? Es gibt vielleicht einen oder anderen. Gut, es gibt eine Stuttgart-Kneipe, es gibt eine Schalke-Kneipe, es gibt eine Frankfurt-Kneipe. Aber auch da ist es halt so, wenn es da voll ist, ist es da voll. Und für viele ist es ja auch so, ich möchte da nicht nur unter Frankfurtern sitzen, sondern ich möchte dann halt auch den Dortmunder daneben dran haben oder den einen Leipziger, den wir regelmäßig haben. Also das ist ja auch ein Leipziger. Ja, wir haben einen Leipziger Stammgast tatsächlich. Der kommt auch im Trikot.
Der steht auch unter Atemschutz bei uns. Da sind wir ja eigentlich beim Grundding.
Fußballknall.
Genau, ja. Also letztendlich, wie Michl gesagt hat, Champions League Bayern Dortmund sind ja eigentlich die Spiele, die jede Sportsbar interessiert, weswegen auch viele ein Abo abschließen. Weil sie sagen, Bayern Champions League, da habe ich die Hütte voll und da mache ich dann den Umsatz und damit kann ich das refinanzieren. Die Abende sind für uns eigentlich sowieso gesetzt. Wir müssen uns auf Abende konzentrieren wie Freitags, Zweite Liga, dass da Leute kommen, dass die Leute Bock aufs Erstligaspiel haben, dass du Donnerstags bei der Europa League Leute da hast und das Schwierigste Sonntags, weil Sonntags interessiert kein Schwein. Egal, wer spielt.
Und jetzt dürfte er auch noch früher aufmachen?
Nein, wir haben ja eh Zweite Liga.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das entwickeln wird nächstes Jahr. Ob das wirklich die Werte kapieren, dass Europa League nur noch auf der Zone kommt, dass die Einzelspiele vielleicht in der Champions League nur noch auf der Zone kommen und ob es dann eine große Offensive gibt, den Leuten das zu erklären, wie man das macht. Ansonsten könnte es in die bisschen falsche Richtung gehen, weil einfach viele nicht mehr vom Fußball mitbekommen, was man eigentlich mitbekommen will, nämlich die Champions League sehen, die wichtigen Spiele. Ich habe sogar das Gefühl irgendwie in den letzten Wochen, dass immer mehr ältere Leute zu uns kommen, weil die das wirklich nicht, die kriegen das mit dem Freitagsspiel halt nicht hin. Die wissen nicht, wie ich einen Eurosport-Player im Internet anschließe. Die hatten vielleicht noch Sky und da ging das mit Fernbedienung und so.
Aber sie wieder auch irgendwie nicht einfach vor ihr Laptop setzen wollen.
Genau, die wollen halt nicht vorm Laptop sitzen.
Ihr habt vorhin schon gesagt, ihr zeigt mehrere Spiele parallel. Das ist ja nur was, wir haben vorher die Kneipe beschrieben als Raum. Ihr habt mich korrigiert, 80 Quadratmeter voll mit Devotionalien. Es ist aber ein Raum. Wie läuft es hier, drei Spiele parallel? Gib mal den den Hörern vielleicht ein bisschen so ein Gefühl. Wie läuft es auch mit dem Ton? Gibt es drei Fernseher oder wie sieht es aus?
Wir haben zwei Beamer mit entsprechend zwei Leidenwänden und haben drei Fernseher, die zum Großteil extra angesteuert werden können über den sogenannten HDMI-Switch, wo ich das HDMI…
Holle, erzähl mal.
Ach, der Holle kann das inzwischen auch. Ich habe halt HDMI-Ausgänge an den Receivers. Wir haben drei Receiver. HDMI-Ausgang in den Switch rein und dann kann ich umschalten. Auf dem Bildschirm soll jetzt der dritte Receiver laufen, auf dem Bildschirm läuft jetzt der erste Receiver, was dann entsprechend ja dann Spiele sind, bzw. Samstagnachmittags läuft bei uns immer die Konferenz und meistens zwei Einzelspiele. Samstagnachmittags ist so immer Konferenzton in der einen Hälfte und in der anderen Hälfte läuft dann oft der Ton zum Beispiel jetzt von einem Einzelspiel. Wir haben dann noch durch unser Separee, unser kleines Separee, was für alle Hörer der Scheißhausgang ist. Da hängt auch ein Fernseher drin, da sind auch Tische drin, da kann man auch ganz gemütlich sitzen und vor allem da können wir halt dann auch nochmal extra am Fernseher einen Ton anmachen, sodass man auch noch irgendwie von einem Einzelspiel einen Ton hören kann.
Das heißt, da läuft in der Regel das dritte Spiel?
Ja, wir machen es oft parallel, also wir haben im großen Gastraum noch einen Fernseher, der dann meistens mit dem Fernseher im Gang gekoppelt ist. Das heißt, die einen, die halt wirklich hier im Gastraum unter allen anderen sitzen wollen, die können ihr Spiel dann, das Einzelspiel ohne Ton schauen und dem halt dann der Ton wichtig ist, der setzt sich dann halt einfach irgendwie hinten rein und wir haben die Boxen, die Lautsprecher heißt das glaube ich inzwischen, so angeordnet, dass es tatsächlich fast eine Trennung gibt von den Tönen. Natürlich sitzt an manchen Plätzen, hörst du einfach beide Töne. Das lässt sich dann halt nicht vermeiden, wenn man keine Tür zu machen kann. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es meistens so, dass man sich nach ein paar Minuten dran gewöhnt hat und den anderen Ton dann einfach irgendwie ausblendet.
Wie früher in der abgetrennten Turlhalle.
Genau.
Und eigentlich ist es ja auch ganz geil. Ich mag das gerade daran, hier dann zu gucken, wenn Konferenzen noch Einzelspiele laufen, dass man eben auch immer noch von dem anderen was mitbekommt. Weil, sagen wir mal ehrlich, nicht jedes Fußballspiel ist auch so über 90 Minuten wirklich packend.
Richtig.
Und dann ist es eigentlich ganz geil, wenn du mitbekommst, oh, die Konferenz ist heute aber richtig cool. Ich drehe mich einfach mal um.
Das ist natürlich auch die große Schwierigkeit und weshalb wir auch eben einen ziemlichen Aufwand haben. Wir übertreiben es auch schon ein bisschen. Dass wir angefangen von den Reservierungen eben uns aufschreiben, wer will das und das Spiel sehen. Also wenn die Mails reinkommen, schreibst du dir auf, der kommt um drei, will Konferenz sehen. Sein Kumpel, die kommen aber zu zweit, der eine will aber noch Einzelspiel BVB sehen. Dementsprechend musst du ihn platzieren.
Legt ihr das vorher fest vor dem Spieltag? Welche Einzelspiele laufen?
Wir legen es vorher zu 90 Prozent fest.
Also es gibt kein Dudel-Steal-Voting, wenn die meisten Einzelspieler BVB reservieren.
Wir reagieren schon drauf, wenn wir überlegen, wir haben jetzt Samstagnachmittagskonferenz und FC Bayern spielen. Da kommt es in München nicht darum herum, FC Bayern als Einzelspiel zu zeigen. Und dann hast du keine Ahnung, ein Spiel wie Mainz gegen Wolfsburg, das musst du jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt als Einzelspiel zeigen. Allerdings, wenn dann plötzlich 15 Leute für dieses Spiel reservieren, dann kann es sein, dass wir das Einzelspiel von BVB gegen Frankfurt, was wir eigentlich gezeigt hätten, weil wir es uns so überlegt haben, dass wir das dann kurzfristig auch nochmal ändern. Also wir reagieren schon auf Reservierungsanfragen, um gegebenenfalls auch nochmal ein Spiel zu ändern.
Ansonsten ist es eine knallharte redaktionelle Auswahl, die wir in vielem vielen Stunden Redaktionssitzung – jeden Morgen um neun treffen vor uns.
Im großen Konferenzraum.
Im großen Konferenzraum, genau.
Zugeschaltet sind noch die wichtigsten Korrespondenten. Aber ihr macht ja alles manuell, oder? Da müsst ihr doch mal unter euren Gästen rumfahren, da muss es doch einen Programmierer geben, der euch da eine Automatisierung macht.
Wir sind oldschool. Das wollen wir auch gar nicht. Wir stehen hier auch mit handgeschriebenen Listen. Wenn Holle da ist, macht er das dann selber. Wenn er nicht da ist, kriege ich eine handgeschriebene Liste in die Hand gedrückt mit Namen drauf, wie viele Plätze reserviert sind und für was und wo die sitzen. So verteilt man dann halt die Leute. Wir könnten uns natürlich auch mit so einem hypermodernen Tablet hinstellen und dann da irgendwie drauf rumklicken. Das wollen wir nicht, wir sind da echt komplett oldschool. Es passt ja auch nichts anderes rein. Also wir hoffen natürlich, dass alle Hörer gerne mal hier vorbeikommen. Und Hörerinnen natürlich. Entschuldigung, ja, mein Gott. Um das hier zu sehen, dass hier halt auch extrem viele alte Sachen hängen und das passt auch überhaupt gar nicht rein. Ich meine, das Modernste sind halt die Beamer und die Fernseher, was wir hier haben und vielleicht noch unsere Kasse. Aber ansonsten ist ja alles irgendwie so alt wie möglich.
Aber gerade mit, also wenn Leute neu da sind, ich glaube, die schütteln schon manchmal einen Kopf und denken, was macht denn der Idiota mit der Liste und warum muss ich mich jetzt auf den Platz setzen? Da vorne ist doch frei und viele fragen dann auch, so, hä, wieso? Ja, du willst doch das und das sehen. Ja, stimmt. Deswegen sitzt du da, weil dann siehst du dein Spiel. Platzanweiser.
Genau, genau.
Und jetzt habt ihr ja logischerweise klare Stoßzeiten. Und es lädt sich ja auch, je nachdem, wie der Spieltag lief, relativ schnell danach. Wie wichtig ist denn für euch das sportliche Abschneiden der Mannschaften? Oder ist es für euch vielleicht eher wichtig, welche Mannschaft in welchem Wettbewerb antritt?
Also da muss ich noch als erstes in die Vergangenheit gehen, so in die ersten zwei, drei Jahre. Weil es lief natürlich nicht von Anfang an, einfach war der Laden voll. Also das war schon auch ein langer Kampf. Auch bis die Leute das angenommen haben und verstanden haben, was wir hier machen. Und natürlich mussten wir da sehr darauf hoffen, dass Bayern zum Beispiel eine Runde weiter kommt in der Champions League. In der Zeit, in der du so krasser Bayern fährst. Ich habe mich tatsächlich zwei, drei Mal beim Jubeln über ein Weiterkommen der Bayern.
Wir müssen kurz sagen, wir haben hier einen Karlsruher mit dem Holle und einen Stuttgarter mit dem Michl. Das ist schon leicht angeklungen von Zeit.
Dass Bayern nicht unsere Lieblinge sind, wissen eigentlich auch alle. Aber damals war das wirklich so. Natürlich ist es inzwischen auch noch so. Klar, freust du dich irgendwie ohnehin, wenn deutsche Mannschaften weiterkommen. Aber natürlich musst du auch dran denken, zum Beispiel jetzt die Zusammenstellung Europa League. Für alle Fußballfans war es irgendwie geil, dass Köln in die Europa League kommt. Wir haben aber auch gewusst, okay, dann haben wir vielleicht Donnerstags mal 20, 30 Leute da zu den Spielen. Und wenn halt, Entschuldigung, Wolfsburg oder Leverkusen da spielen, kommt halt eher niemand aus. Das ist ein großer Gegner da.
Also geht es eher um die…
Es geht ums sportliche Abschneiden, es geht auch um Auf-Abstieg. Beispiel, letzte Saison, zweite Liga lief mit Stuttgart überragend. Jetzt kommt wieder kaum jemand zu Stuttgart. Obwohl wir es auch als Einzelspiel zeigen. Abstieg 1860, Abstieg KSC für uns nicht gut. Können wir nicht mehr zeigen, verlieren einen Haufen Gäste. Dafür haben wir einen treuen Heidenheimer, der zweite Liga guckt. Und einen treuen Sandhäuser, zwei sogar. Jetzt ist gerade der Club wieder im Kommen. Dementsprechend kommen wieder ein paar mehr Clubfans. Düsseldorf läuft wieder gut.
Union läuft sowieso super.
Unioner sind immer da, bei denen ist es egal. Jetzt waren ein paar Duisburger da und wir hatten sogar die ersten Holstein-Kiel-Fans. Das ist natürlich total schön, weil du mit denen auch sofort ins Gespräch kommst und sagst, wie kommst du jetzt da drauf? Hab gehört, hier kann ich zweite Liga, hier kann ich meinen Verein gucken. So finanziell lukrativ ist es aber halt nicht, wenn vier Leute da sitzen und ihren Verein gucken. Aber so ist es halt. Dafür ist es einfach auch Fußball. Und du bist von Ergebnissen abhängig. Wird bei der WM genau das gleiche sein, wenn Deutschland im Viertelfinale ausscheidet, können wir den Rest relativ in die Tonne kloppen. Relativ.
Also, um das vielleicht ein bisschen zu relativieren mit dem FC Bayern, das ist tatsächlich so, dass es halt früher einfach irgendwie wichtiger war. Aber wir haben inzwischen ja auch schon so ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein Standing auch bei internationalen Gästen, also relativ große Bekanntheit auch. Sagen wir mal, gut, wenn Bayern die Vorrunde nicht übersteht, was ja eigentlich so gut wie ausgeschlossen ist, wenn die die Vorrunde nicht überstehen würden, das wäre natürlich schon eine mittlere Katastrophe in finanzieller Hinsicht. Sagen wir mal, Bayern scheidet im Viertelfinale aus. Okay, macht jetzt nicht viel aus, dann spielt halt Barca gegen Real oder Barca gegen PSG. Da haben wir dann auch voll. Wir machen dann zwar nicht die Umsätze, weil da kommt viele Neutrale, die sich es halt einfach gemütlich anschauen wollen und trinken ein paar Bier dazu.
Das heißt, die besseren Fans sind die, die für ihren Verein da sind, weil die mehr ans Feierboden sind?
Ja, das ist ja auch mehr Enthusiasmus, es ist viel mehr Spannung da, wenn du mit deinem eigenen Verein dann irgendwie mitfieberst, als wenn du jetzt ganz neutral irgendwie Barca gegen Real anguckst. Es mag zwar ein absolut geiles Spiel sein und da ist auch extrem viel Brisanz drin, sicherlich, aber ich schaue es mir neutral an und dann trinke ich halt irgendwie statt, ich sag mal sechs Bier, trinke ich halt nur drei Bier und das macht dann halt schon ein bisschen was aus.
Und geh auf jeden Fall auch nach dem Spiel nach Hause, wenn es immer mal was zu feiern gibt, dann bleibe ich vielleicht auch mal eine halbe Stunde länger und haue mir noch drei Schnaps rein. Wenn du mit deinem Verein mitfieberst.
Aber dass wir hier in der Champions League auch im Finale, das ist eigentlich auch schon irgendwie wurscht, wer im Finale spielt, da wird es auf jeden Fall voll sein. Also wir haben uns da so ein Standing einfach auch erarbeitet, dass wir auch diese Spiele vollkriegen. Schwierig ist natürlich tatsächlich, also Zweite Liga problematisch. Andererseits im Übrigen auch zu viel Erfolg. Die letzten Jahre im FC Bayern, es ist, wenn die so früh Meister werden.
Kommt am 30.
Spieltag keiner mehr. Da kommen halt dann andere wieder, aber es kommen halt nicht dann die großen Bayern-Fans, sondern dann wissen vielleicht auch andere, Bayern ist eh Meister, da zeigen sie das Einzelspiel gar nicht. Dann reserviere ich jetzt mal irgendwie für Dortmund oder reserviere ich für Frankfurt. Vielleicht zeigen sie ja dann dieses Einzelspiel, worauf wir dann tatsächlich auch häufig irgendwie eingehen.
Was es immer wieder, wenn wir bei den letzten Spieltagen sind, ist es immer wieder geil, dass dann am 30. Spieltag oder gegebenenfalls dann am 32. Spieltag immer irgendwie zwei oder drei Fernsehteams da sind, Meisterschaft des FC Bayern. Und die müssen dann die fünf Leute, die hier verpackt sind, nicht feiern oder wenig feiern. Und ihr nächster Halt ist dann immer an der Leopoldstraße, obwohl wir sagen, da braucht er doch gar nicht hinfahren. Das sind jedes Jahr die gleichen Bilder.
Und jedes Jahr muss unser FC Bayern-Edelfan Joshi herhalten.
Genau, es sind immer die gleichen. Das ist super.
Das klingt aber schon so, dass heute Gäste quasi ausschließlich für die jeweiligen Spiele, die an dem Tag laufen, kommen. Habt ihr Gäste, die, keine Ahnung, wir sitzen hier an, ich würde mal sagen an einem Tisch, der prädestiniert ist für einen Stammtisch, die einfach kommen, weil sie, keine Ahnung, jede Woche am Dienstag kommen mit einer Runde von Leuten und einfach immer da sind oder einfach kommen, weil sie sagen, oder läuft ein bisschen Fußball nebenbei, was das jetzt ist, ist es mir egal, aber das ist halt meine Kneipe und da gehe ich hin.
Solche Gäste haben wir auch, aber das sind jetzt weniger Stammtische, also überhaupt die ganze Stammtischkultur ist ein bisschen verloren gegangen in den letzten Jahren. Also wir haben einen relativ regelmäßigen Stammtisch, die kommen aber auch zu den Spielen. Die kommen aber hauptsächlich zu den Bayernspielen, aber auch vielleicht mal sonst so. Aber wir haben einfach extrem viele Stammgäste, die einfach hierher kommen, völlig unabhängig, ob jetzt ihr Verein spielt oder nicht.
Extrem viele, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Wir haben keine Stammtisch, sondern so die Stammbar. Da vorne ist unsere Ostkurve. Das ist die Expertenrunde. Das sind unsere Stammgäste, denen es auch wurscht ist, was für ein Spiel kommt. Das ist auch ein netter Nebeneffekt, die sich hier kennengelernt haben. Inzwischen sind sie teilweise auch Freunde. Da entwickelt sich auch was draus, wenn man gemeinsam an irgendwelchen Tischen sitzt. Oder sitzen muss, weil wir sind so platziert.
Weil der Schalker neben Dortmund sitzt.
Das ist auch manchmal ein ganz nettes Spiel, wenn man die Leute so zusammensetzt und man die selber kennt und denkt, die könnten eigentlich ganz gut zusammenpassen.
Stimmt, das habe ich auch schon mal erlebt. Ich bin hier reingekommen und hast dir gesagt, ich habe dich neben den Eintracht Frankfurt-Fanclub-Leiter des Fanclubs aus Texas gesetzt. Mit dem musst du reden, der ist super.
Ja, so entsteht halt auch die Kommunikation. Aber so mit Stammtischen?
Nein, Stammtische nicht. Wir haben schon Gruppen da, die regelmäßig kommen. Aber das ist dann hauptsächlich für ihre Spiele oder für ihren Verein. Und wenn sie dann nur einmal im Monat kommen. Aber die kommen halt dann. Das zähle ich dann schon eher unter Stammgäste. Weil das, was Holle erzählt hat, ist tatsächlich die Expertenrunde. Das sind auch viele einzelne Personen. Da gehört dann eben ein Sandhausen-Fan, ein Heidenheim-Fan, ein Ingolstadt-Fan dazu. Das macht dir auch dann irgendwie Spaß. Und dann kommt noch ein Sechziger dazu oder zwei oder drei Sechziger dazu. So vermischt sich das dann halt. Und dann redet man halt einfach über Fußball oder dummes Zeug, was meistens irgendwie einhergeht.
Aber ihr habt tatsächlich ja auch, wir haben da im Vorfeld schon mal darüber gesprochen gehabt, relativ viele Gäste, die einfach zu Besuch in München sind und vorbeikommen und von euch gehört haben. Und es waren auch durchaus schon namhafte Gäste da. Sei es jetzt denn, wir haben im Vorsprung Kalli gehört, im Rahmen von einer Lesung oder von einer Diskussionsrunde. Kommt da, passiert es dann auch, dass hin und wieder einfach mal jemand bei der Tür reinkommt, den man kennt, Spieler, Trainer, irgendwie mit Fußball verbunden?
Das aktuellste Beispiel war am Freitag, Donnerstag, Deutschland gegen Nordirland, stand plötzlich ein Typ an unserer Säule da in der Mitte. Ich denke mir, kennste doch. Er war ein Schlagzeuger von Sportfreunden Stiller. Und ich bin mir sicher, wir erkennen viele gar nicht. Das kann gut sein. Unabhängig vom Fußball sind München Promidichte. Bis wir mal gewusst haben, wer Friedrich Mücke ist, bis er es uns gesagt hat, Schauspieler. Hat es auch gedauert. Klar, wenn du ehemalige Fußballer da hast, dann solltest du die schon erkennen.
Was aber teilweise auch echt schwierig ist. Also auch mit aktuellen Fußballern.
Also mit diesen ganzen Promi-Gedöns oder so. Natürlich ist es hauptsächlich so, dass die dann zu Lesungen kommen, weil sie eingeladen sind. Oder weil sie eben auch als Zuschauer kommen, weil sie eben Kumpels sind von demjenigen, der sein Buch vorstellt oder bei einer Diskussionsrunde dabei ist. Ja, aber manchmal ist es schon auch passiert, dass wir gedacht haben, er hat den Kemmer doch. Und dann war mal der Duffner, der ehemalige Manager von dem Ding, oder Franz Xaver Wack stand jetzt hier mal da. Den haben wir dann auch kennengelernt. Oder es sind öfters mal kleinere Mediendrehs, die dann irgendwie einen Experten mitbringen. Oder dann plötzlich Jungwon Ahn hier stand. Und dem Panini-Album Seidank habe ich den dann eben auch noch erkannt, der damals 2002 das Tor gegen Italien geschossen hat für Südkorea. Solche absurden Gäste sind dann schon hier. Oder es kommt eben irgendjemand und sagt, ich habe euch heute den und den mitgebracht, den ehemaligen japanischen Nationaltrainer.
Auch von 2002?
Ja, genau. Oder einen zweiten Trainer von Barcelona aktuell. Oder es sind irgendwelche 60 Spieler da gewesen. Wer zum Beispiel auch privat kommt, ist Jan Mauersberger von 60. Ja, solche Geschichten. Und der bringt dann auch wieder irgendeinen Mitspieler mit. Oder beim Fußball-Quiz diese Woche kommen wahrscheinlich wieder Stefan Hain und Bigalke. Also wurde uns zugetragen, dass die wieder am Start sein werden. Ralf Gunes ist dann auch wieder am Start mit seinem Twitter-Team.
Vielleicht wollen wir da mal noch kurz ein Wort drüber verlieren. Das Fußball-Quiz hat ja durchaus Bekanntheit erlangt, aber auch nicht für jeden. Sag doch mal kurz, was hat es damit auf sich? Wie kommt es dazu?
Ich hatte schon immer irgendwie den Gedanken, wir müssen einen Fußball-Quiz hier machen. Und irgendwann kamen dankbarerweise zwei absolute Vollbekloppte zu mir und sagten, wir würden gerne einen Fußball-Quiz machen. Organisiert ihr das? Ja, das organisieren wir. Gut, dann versuchen wir das mal. Einmal im Monat Donnerstags. Hat von Anfang an gut Zuspruch gehabt. Läuft so, dass du drei Runden hast, drei Zettel ausgeteilt kriegst, die du ausfüllen musst. Im Ende steht das Sieger fest. Aber schon beim ersten Quiz war eben Uwe Morave da, Kommentator damals noch Sport1 und hat halt mit 30 Punkten Vorsprung gewonnen, weil er einfach das wandelnde Lexikon ist. Und dann haben wir gemerkt, ok, Quiz ist geil, aber irgendwas müssen wir mit diesem Morave machen. Haben das Ding dann unbenannt, entschlagt den Morave. Und er muss pro Runde eine Zusatzfrage stellen, in denen er für die er keine Punkte kriegen kann, um den anderen eine Chance zu geben.
Tolle Chance. Inzwischen stellt er halt Fragen, die kann halt kein Mensch beantworten.
So hat er Fragen aus den 30er Jahren und so. Weil inzwischen hat sich so entwickelt, dass Uwe nur noch sehr selten gewinnt, weil die Mannschaften, also wir waren früher auch, wir haben das hier vom Stadionteam spielt auch immer mit. Wir wissen ja von den Fragen nichts, weil die Jungs, die zwei Jungs das immer noch selber machen. Das ist glaube ich das 60ste. Die haben immer noch Ideen für geile Fragestellungen, obwohl eigentlich alles schon mal da war. Aber die Teams sind inzwischen so gut, dass wir froh sind, wenn wir irgendwie – inzwischen sind es fast schon – Fünfter oder unter die Top Ten. Das ist teilweise auch schon ein Erfolg, weil es halt über 20 Teams sind und da eben gnadenlose Nerbteams dabei sind, die alles wissen. Muss man auch sagen, dass die das teilweise beruflich machen. Aber wer vorhin bei den Promis war, Mats Hummels war auch schon mehrfach beim Quiz dabei. Und der ist dann eben Drittletzter geworden. Also das sagt eigentlich alles.
Aber kann er damit umgehen? Kennt er ja gar nicht mehr.
Kann er. Und da muss man auch dazu sagen, und da sind wir extrem dankbar, dass unsere Gäste das natürlich toll finden, dass er da ist, Mats Hummels, oder wenn jetzt jemand anderes da ist, dass die dem aber nicht auf den Sack gehen. Die lassen ihn in Ruhe. Vielleicht so kurz vor Ende fragt mal einer, kann ich vielleicht doch ein Foto haben? Aber ansonsten ist da kein Aufheben oder sonst irgendwas von unserer Seite erst recht nicht. Und die Gäste respektieren das total und das ist schön. Womit wir beim Respekt sind, was für den Laden immer noch so das eigentlich für mich das größte oder das worauf ich stolz bin, das größte Aushängeschild ist, dass die Gäste sich untereinander respektieren, die für ihre verschiedenen Vereine sind.
Gab es hier da mal Probleme auch oder? In den alten Jahren nie?
Wirklich nicht. In elf Jahren keine Schlägerei. Also es vermuten ja viele und ich glaube, es kommen auch viele nicht hierher, weil sie denken, Fußballkneipe, nur Assis. Hör ich immer wieder. Ist echt interessant. Aber es ist wirklich nicht.
Aber es sind hier eher so die Akademiker, die Fußballkneipe.
Wir sind schon ein Querschnitt in der Bevölkerung. Wir haben von der Altersstruktur zwischen 18 und 16-Jährigen hierher. Aber das geht dann auch echt hoch bis 70 oder 75. Und vom Bauarbeiter bis zum Professor. Genau, Eltern mit Kindern kommen inzwischen relativ häufig.
Frauen kommen hier. Wir hatten hier auch schon Tinder-Dates. Oh ja, stimmt. Die Struktur ist echt einfach interessant. Und das ist auch gleichbleibend geworden.
Habt ihr da irgendeine Veränderung festgestellt? Es gibt da so ein paar große Thesen zur Entwicklung des Fußballs. Die eine ist, das Interesse lässt langsam nach, was man bei Quoten und so weiter eigentlich nicht sehen kann. Das andere ist, es ist eben Querschnitt der Gesellschaft. Wie hat sich das entwickelt? Wie seht ihr das?
Ich glaube, in der Anfangszeit, ohne jetzt irgendwie Holle vorgreifen zu wollen, aber in der Anfangszeit war es schon tatsächlich so, dass hier einfach richtige Fußballfans hier waren und man als Neutraler eigentlich gar nicht so hergekommen ist. Ich glaube, dass sich das inzwischen so ein bisschen gewandelt hat. Man trifft sich hier einfach auch. Man schaut manchmal tatsächlich auch nur nebenher Fußball. Wenn jetzt auch irgendwie Champions League ist und BVB spielt, haben wir zwar echt sehr viele BVB-Fans, aber wir haben halt auch viele Neutrale. Ich als Stuttgart-Fan schaue mir auch BVB in der Champions League an und so machen es halt viele andere dann auch. Die treffen sich und sagen, oh Gott, heute Abend spielt BVB gegen Real, das muss man ja eigentlich irgendwie anschauen. Dann hocken wir uns halt mal hin, dann schauen wir das Spiel, unterhalten uns halt natürlich irgendwie so ein bisschen nebenher über alles Mögliche. Aber man schaut dann halt einfach auch irgendwie gemeinsam das Spiel. Das war, glaube ich, früher nicht so.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Es stimmt schon. Also es war schon eher auf die Vereine fixiert und wirklich Fans teilweise auch. Ja, die härtere Fraktion. Ja, aber auch da nie was passiert.
Aber es ist auch tatsächlich lustig, dass es Gäste gibt, die dann, auch wenn sie Bayern-Fans sind und es einfach nicht schaffen, hier einen Platz zu kriegen, weil sie entweder zu spät reservieren oder dann irgendwie bis um acht arbeiten müssen und da ist halt bei uns meistens schon irgendwie voll. Die kommen dann halt zu einem anderen Champions League Spiel und dann gibt es tatsächlich Gäste, die dann auch sagen, wir haben endlich mal einen Platz hier gekriegt. Und ich muss jetzt einfach mal zu einem anderen Spiel kommen, damit ich endlich mal irgendwie hier drin bin. Also es ist schon irgendwie völlig crazy, aber es ist manchmal ganz lustig.
Aber so eine Fußballmüdigkeit, stellt ihr das fest? Oder auch, ich meine, viele Entwicklungen im Fußball, immer mehr Kommerz. Ich meine, wir haben ja auch schon so mit TV-Rechten und sowas dieses Thema gestreift und letztlich auch mit der Zusammensetzung der Ligen. Also wir haben jetzt einfach Mannschaften wie Hoffenheim und Leipzig, die ihre Fan-Basis sich zum Teil erst noch aufbauen müssen, sagen wir es mal so, zum Teil schon ein bisschen größer haben.
So hast du echt schön ausgedrückt.
Ich bin ein, ich will ja auch jetzt hier nicht, ich will ja nicht die erste Prögelei hier an im Stadion.
Die Fußballmüdigkeit, ja, irgendwie ist sie schon da. Mein 27 Leute bei einem Länderspiel Deutschland ist jetzt wirklich nicht so handgezählt.
Also es war gestern Deutschland gegen Aserbaidschan.
Es war gestern Abend Deutschland gegen Aserbaidschan. Klar ist alles entschieden und so, aber trotzdem bei einem Länderspiel hattest du sonst einfach immer mehr Leute da. Auch dieses Nebenbei-Schauen, wie Michl sagt, dass es eher so ein Zusammenhocken ist, aber eigentlich interessierst du dich gar nicht so wirklich für das Spiel. Das kriegen wir mit. Dann, dass viele sagen, in die Allianz Arena gehe ich nicht mehr. Ist mir echt zu blöd und zu aufgeblasen alles.
Oder andersrum, kurzfristige Reservierungsabsagen. Wir haben zu zehnt noch Karten gekriegt in der Allianz Arena, was es früher ja nie gab. In der letzten Saison hat es schon angefangen. In der Saison setzt sich es eigentlich fort. Wir haben eigentlich an jedem Spieltag Bundesliga mindestens eine Reservierungsabsage, weil es noch Karten gab für die Arena. Diese Fußballmütigkeit merken wir jetzt hier nicht unbedingt an der Gästeanzahl, sondern eher in Gesprächen. Das ist, was viele Gäste einfach sagen. Es wird mir zu blöd und es ist alles zu viel. Es geht nur noch ums Geld. Jetzt auch mit Eurosport. Dann muss man noch einem Rechte, damit man noch mehr Geld rausholen kann. Die Leidtragenden sind dann wieder Fußballfans. In der Hinsicht habe ich schon den Eindruck, dass es eine Fußballmütigkeit gibt oder die langsam zunimmt. Es ist, glaube ich, auch eine recht bedenkliche Entwicklung. Wenn so etwas mal anfängt, kann das auch ganz schnell eine Eigendynamik kriegen. Man hört es auch immer wieder von Fußballfans, auch jetzt in Fernsehberichten oder Radioreportagen oder sowas, dass es immer mehr gibt bzw. diese Stimmen immer lauter werden, dass es nur noch um Kommerz geht und noch mehr Vermarktung und hier noch was. Dann muss die DFL noch mal 300 Millionen mehr rausholen und dann wechseln Spieler für 222 Millionen oder wieviel auch immer. Das sind Zwischendimensionen. Früher waren das schon Dimensionen, wo man schon den Kopf geschüttelt hat, wenn man auf seine eigene Gehaltsabrechnung geschaut hat. Aber das wird immer schlimmer und die Schere wird immer größer. Es ist eine Art Entfremdung fast zu einem Fußballspieler. Auch eingefleischte Bayern-Fans gibt es, die sagen, Lewandowski, warum muss der jetzt jährlich im zweistelligen Millionenbereich verdienen? Dann macht er dann noch so einen Ego-Trip. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig. Fußball wird zum Teil, von den Spielern her, zum Teil geht es nur um einen selbst. Es sind Ego-Trips. Man wechselt dann einfach nicht mehr zum Training, weil man zum FC Barcelona wechseln will, was für einen normalen Fußball-Fan überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar ist. Nicht nur für den, das ist überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar, weil es mit der Realität nichts mehr zu tun hat. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem, dass alles, was im Fußball-Business passiert, nichts mehr mit Realität zu tun hat und nicht mit dem eigenen Leben, das entfremdet sich komplett.
Als Fußball-Fan ist die Schere zu groß. Du weißt, in der Bundesliga, wenn nicht sehr viel danebenläuft, wird Bayern Meister. Das ist tödlich langweilig. Du weißt, in der Champions League, es werden im Viertelfinale ein Außenzeiter sein und sieben, die da sowieso immer spielen. Auch im Pokalfinale weißt du, dass eigentlich die Bayern da stehen oder Dortmund. Also Spannung sehr wenig. Die Leute konzentrieren sich lieber auf einen Abstiegskampf.
Das war tatsächlich die letzten Jahre so, dass es hier eigentlich hauptsächlich irgendwie um Abstiegskampf ging. Es ging nicht mal darum, wer kommt in die Euro League oder wer kommt in die Champions League, sondern das haben sich echt die meisten einfach nur noch für einen Abstiegskampf interessiert und steigt der HSV jetzt endlich mal ab und wird diese Scheißuhr endlich abmontiert. Also dass es darum geht, ob jetzt Dortmund zweiter oder dritter wird.
Wir haben auch Gäste, das merkt man in Gesprächen, die regelmäßig irgendwie die Möglichkeit hätten, weil jemand ein Ticket übrig hat, sich Bayern in der Champions League in der Allianz Arena anzuschauen. Aber die sagen auch, ich habe keinen Bock drauf. Also ich will schon gar nicht die Kohle ausgeben. Und mich kickt es aber auch nicht. Ich gehe lieber am Samstag nach Garching und schaue mir die Regionalliga an, weil ich da Fußball erlebe und nicht irgendwas hochgezüchtetes, was, wie Michl sagt, nichts mit der Realität mehr zu tun hat. Wobei ich auch glaube, das gehen wir mal in eine ganz andere Richtung, dass es auch für die Spieler selber nicht der allergrößte Spaß ist, einfach nur ein Objekt zu sein, das einen taxierten Marktwert hat. Manche galt es vielleicht auf, noch einen Vertrag zu kriegen, wo man noch mal 20 Millionen mehr kriegt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die das meistens selbst wollen, sondern dass da die Berater schuld sind, die ihnen eintrichtern, wir müssen das jetzt machen. Es ist halt ein riesengroßer Zirkus, bei dem es nur noch um Geld geht. Genau, und du bist derjenige, der auf dem Platz rum stolzieren darf.
Weil aber auch der sportliche Wettbewerb irgendwie so entwertet wird. Klar, wenn wir jetzt über die Top-Verdiener sprechen, da geht es darum, ob die mit dem nächsten Vertrag noch mal x Millionen mehr bekommen. Aber es gibt ja einen riesigen, ich hätte fast gesagt Bodensatz, aber das wäre ja despektierlich, aber der Durchschnitts-Bundesliga-Profi und auch Zweitliga-Profi, der verdient ja gar nicht so.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz, ganz hartes, ganz, ganz hartes Brot.
Und gleichzeitig treten die in einem Wettbewerb an, wo sie wissen, wenn ich irgendwas ganz Fantastisches, wenn ich irgendwie in Leicester City passiert, dann werde ich nie Deutscher Meister. Eventuell werde ich auch nie aufsteigen. Und das finde ich eigentlich so die krasse Entwicklung der letzten Jahre, dass ich – ich höre ja viele Podcasts, auch von anderen Vereinen logischerweise und Eintracht Frankfurt Podcasts oder wer auch immer – die leben quasi in der Gewissheit, ich werde nie mehr in meiner Fußball-Fan-Biografie Deutscher Meister werden. Für mich ist sowas wie jetzt das verlorene Pokalfinale gegen Borussia Dortmund wahrscheinlich das Highlight für die nächsten zehn Jahre. Und das ist ja unfassbar krass, wie sich das verändert hat. Also wir sind ja alle noch so aufgewachsen, dass es zwar schon relativ, es gab so Grundfesten an Mannschaften, die vorhin drin sind. Es gab immer einen Rivalen zum Beispiel zu Bayern, aber der hat zum Beispiel auch gewechselt.
Ich habe Anfang tatsächlich Anfang 90ern zumindest den Minifunken Hoffnung gehabt, dass mein KSC irgendwann mal Deutscher Meister werden könnte. Weil ich gesehen habe, okay, KSL hat das geschafft. Vielleicht und dieses Jahr, diese Saison auch mal gut eingekauft. Vielleicht könnten wir echt und die Bayern schwächeln und das kannst du vergessen heutzutage.
Kannst du vergessen.
Du kannst dir vielleicht darauf hoffen, wie du sagst, mit Frankfurt, dass du mal ins Pokalfinale kommst. Aber ansonsten?
Wann war der letzte Deutscher Meister außer Bayern und Dortmund? 2009 Wolfsburg und davor 2007 Stuttgart. Und das sind jetzt innerhalb von 10 Jahren hast du eigentlich nur Bayern, ein bisschen Dortmund und dann noch zwei mehr oder weniger Überraschungsmeisterschaften. Aber sowas ist jetzt 10 Jahre später eigentlich fast nicht mehr möglich. Also das, egal wie gut sie spielen, aber dass Hoffenheim irgendwie um die Meisterschaft mitspielt in der Saison ist glaube ich relativ aussichtslos.
Man muss ja dazu sagen, dass das in anderen Ländern noch viel krasser ist. Also ich sag mal kleinere Ligen. Griechenland. Wird mal jemand anderes Meister als Olympiakus? Nein. In Kroatien hat es jetzt mal funktioniert, nach ganz vielen Jahren, dass Rejeka Meister geworden ist. In Frankreich.
Ich wurde noch mit Olympique Lyon sozialisiert. Das war für mich quasi der Serienmeister.
Wie auch 6 oder 7 Mal.
Richtig.
Aber letztlich wurde es halt nur ersetzt durch einen anderen.
Spanien, also wenn wir bei den großen Ligen sind. Barca oder Real oder Real oder Barca.
Zwischendrin vielleicht noch Athletico, aber das war's dann. Eigentlich in England hast du ja auch nur irgendwie die Top 5 oder jetzt Lester irgendwie reingekommen ist.
Mit Lester war ja überragend. Da haben wir uns echt ein zweites Loch in den Arsch gefreut, dass sowas noch möglich ist. Und wenn es so weit ist, das noch.
Gut, andererseits muss man in England auch sagen, du hast tatsächlich irgendwie die Top 5. Arsenal wird es wahrscheinlich die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht schaffen. selbst mit Klopp wahrscheinlich irgendwie schwierig. Dieses Jahr wird wahrscheinlich kein Weg an Man City irgendwie vorbeigehen. Vielleicht doch Manchester United. Kommt Chelsea nochmal irgendwie. Gut, andererseits muss man halt sagen, da steckt halt einfach nur unglaublich viel Kohle drin. Und auch in Spanien jetzt die zwei großen, wie viel Schulden die haben. Also da muss ich tatsächlich sagen, ich verstehe, also bei so wenig wie ich den FC Bayern auch irgendwie mag. Ich finde es interessant, dass es eigentlich so gut wie keinen Aufschrei gibt beim FC Bayern, weil was in der Champions League passiert ist, ganz klare Wettbewerbsverzerrung. Der FC Bayern hat ein Festgeldkonto, hat keine Schulden. Kann man jetzt sagen, sind sie selber daran schuld, wenn sie keinen Spieler für 222 Millionen kaufen, obwohl sie das Geld hätten. Aber wenn man mal die großen Vereine sieht, die die Champions League im Grunde unter sich ausmachen, die haben alle ex orbitant hohe Schulden. Und das ist für mich eine ganz klare Wettbewerbsverzerrung. Also in Deutschland kannst du ja nicht mehr irgendwie sagen, ja der FC Bayern, der kauft ja alles irgendwie zusammen. Wenn die jetzt irgendwie Schulden hätten, aber Schulden hat ein Verein wie FC Schalke zum Beispiel oder unsere Freunde vom Hamburger SV. Unsere Freunde vom Hamburger, nein, unser Freund vom Hamburger SV, der den Verein seit Jahren am Leben hält. Da kannst du dann natürlich irgendwie fragen, als Werder Bremen, die seit Jahren da unten irgendwie mitspielen oder auch als Stuttgart vorletztes Jahr abgestiegen, wo wir jetzt, sagen wir mal, zumindest keine großen Schulden haben, aber wo ist da jetzt irgendwie eine Gleichheit, eine Chancengleichheit auch? Ganz schlimm ist es halt dann tatsächlich in der Champions League und da hörst du gar nichts vom FC Bayern.
Ja, stimmt, tut man nicht. Andererseits immer mal wieder schon. Ich hab ein – das ist jetzt ein bisschen off-topic, aber ich hab gestern bei der Recherche zu einer anderen Podcastaufnahme, habe ich ein Zwei-Minuten-Interview von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge auf der großen US-Tour gesehen vom FC Bayern. Da saß er dann im eigens designten Polo-Show für die Tour und hat dann darüber gesprochen, dass er mit dem Besitzer der New England Patriots zusammensaß. Erstmal ist ihm der Name nicht eingefallen, dieses Postner-Teams, da hat ihm jemand gesagt, hier New England Patriots und da hat er gesagt, dann habe ich ihn gefragt, wie viele Spieler haben sie denn? Da hat er gesagt, 53 und Michl, wir zwei, wir schauen American Football, wir wissen, okay, das ist halt einfach der Kader in einem NFL-Team und für ihn war aber diese Zahl so wahnsinnig hoch und er hat das dann auf den Fußball übertragen, hat gesagt, und wenn wir noch, wenn wir jetzt weiter so viele Spiele machen müssen, vielleicht brauchen wir irgendwann dann auch 43 oder 450 Spiele.
Tellerrand und so.
Man muss sich jetzt nur irgendwie dran denken. Aber ist das dann für euch so ein Thema, was euch nur privat interessiert oder hat es auch wirklich hier für das Starten an der Schleißheimer Straße eine Bedeutung oder auch vielleicht auch für andere Fußballkneipen? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt ja schon rausgehört bei euch, läuft das jetzt über die Jahre gesehen schon ganz gut und du sagst ja, voller als voll können wir nicht sein.
Also ich warte schon, ich warte eigentlich schon seit Jahren darauf, dass der, dass der Hype abnimmt. Er nimmt auch ab. Aber was ich seit Jahren auch befürchte, dass es echt mal vorbei ist einfach, dass die Leute sagen so, nee, ich habe keinen Bock mehr drauf, ich will das nicht mehr sehen, es interessiert mich auch nicht mehr. Ja, das ist dann doch noch nicht ganz in Sicht. Zum Glück für uns, weil ganz wichtig, dass wir das auch noch dazu sagen, natürlich gehören wir mit einem ganz kleinen Anteil auch zu diesem Geschäft. Wir leben auch davon, dass Dembele im Barca-Trikot herumspringt und die Leute das sehen wollen und Neymar bei PSG. Ganz klar, auch von solchen Entwicklungen wie Angelotti zu Heinkels wieder, was mit dem Hype nichts zu tun hat. Natürlich werden wir jetzt am Samstag die Hütte plötzlich wieder mit Bayern-Fans voll haben, weil die das sehen wollen. Ganz klar, wir gehören auch zu dem Geschäft. Den Hype meine ich seit 2006. Aber das merkt man auch bei den Turnieren. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Euphorie trotz Titelverteidigung jetzt für die WM in Russland so riesengroß sein wird. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Da gibt es aber tatsächlich auch noch ein paar andere Faktoren, was ja auch wieder mit dem ganzen Fußballgeschäft zu tun hat. Also überhaupt das Thema WM in Russland vier Jahre später, WM in Katar, was tatsächlich unter unseren Gästen auch immer wieder irgendwie ein Thema ist. Es sind immer so kleine Bausteine, die einen so ein bisschen nachdenken lassen, wie weit soll das überhaupt noch gehen, wie weit kann das noch gehen. Gut, wir wissen es alle aus, im privaten Leben immer höher, immer schneller, immer weiter kann irgendwann mal nicht funktionieren. Es sollte eigentlich auch in der Börse irgendwie bekannt sein, aber da wird es ja irgendwie weiterhin propagiert, auch in vielen Unternehmen wird es halt weiter propagiert. Es wird alles seine natürlichen Grenzen haben, beim Fußball ist man sich da manchmal nicht so ganz sicher, weil die ja in ihrer eigenen Welt irgendwie leben. Aber ist schon immer dieser Gedanke da, wo führt das jetzt noch hin, wie weit geht das noch, dann liest du hier wieder was von Korruption, Bestechung. Das geht ja auch, genau wollte ich gerade sagen. Das sind so viele kleine Bausteine, die da immer wieder irgendwie aufpoppen und das ist jetzt, dann kann Rayo Seppelt noch so große und wunderbare Dopingreportagen oder Dokumentationen machen. Es scheint sich ja überhaupt gar nichts zu ändern, weil es ist ja praktisch jeden Tag oder zumindest jede Woche hörst du wieder irgendwas von da und jetzt war wieder was mit Rio und was der alles irgendwie mit Gold barren und weiß Gott was, was man immer irgendwie liest. Es sind immer so kleine Bausteine und der Turm. Und der große Überbegriff ist die Glaubwürdigkeit. Die Glaubwürdigkeit kommt halt einfach dazu, ja.
Also es glaubt ja auch niemand mehr, dass irgendein Land, weil es so eine tolle Präsentation gemacht hat, eine WM kriegt. Das Thema ist durch, da sagt jeder, ist doch eh geschoben. Dann müssen wir uns halt damit abfinden.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon das Buch Football Leaks gelesen habt. Da fängt man auch wirklich nochmal, also man weiß ja schon viel, vor allem wenn man sich mit dem Fußball beschäftigt, aber da erfährt man nochmal so viel mehr Details, dass du komplett anders über Spielertransfers nachdenkst. Ich kann nicht aufhören, wenn jetzt ein Spieler quäligt vom Tor, drüber nachzudenken, ob er sich in seinen Vertrag auch eine Assistprämie hat reinschreiben lassen und ob die genauso hoch ist wie die Torprämie, die er gehabt hätte. Das ist schon interessant, je mehr man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Und auf der anderen Seite stelle ich aber auch fest, und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen, ich meine, den Rasenfunk gibt es ja auch aus dem Grund aus so einer Unzufriedenheit mit der gängigen Berichterstattung, deswegen versuchen wir es ja so unser Ding damit zu machen. Aber ich stelle auch fest, so unterm Strich interessiert es die Leute dann halt ehrlich gesagt doch nicht. Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel neulich ein Artikel drüber gelesen, es gab doch diese große Spielmanipulations- Enthüllung gar nicht so lange her, ich würde sagen eineinhalb, zwei Jahre, wo irgendwie raus kam, also 500 Spiele europaweit und auch in der 2. Liga, auch in der 3. Liga kam vor. Habt man da noch mal was von gehört? Und ich weiß aber, also wenn wir jetzt im Rasenfunk dazu ne Folge machen, könnte auch sein, dass ich vielleicht auch deswegen diesen Artikel gestern noch mal gelesen habe, dann würde das schon die Leute, die uns jetzt schon hören, die würden das sich dann anhören und würden dann auch hoffentlich sagen, gutes Thema, gut, dass da mal wieder jemand was drüber gemacht hat, aber es wird nie die breite Masse interessieren, weil denen das immer eigentlich, auch Doping und so weiter, das ist ja, aber weil du ja auch keine klaren Statements irgendwie dazu kriegst.
Frag doch mal beim DFB nach zu diesem Thema. Glaubst du vielleicht, da stellt sich irgendjemand hin und erklärt dir irgendwas dazu? Das ist ja immer das Große, das wird ja alles irgendwie immer versucht, unter den Teppich zu kehren. Das ist ja auch diese ganze, da hörst du wieder irgendwie von Russland, ob das jetzt irgendwie Sochi war oder jetzt irgendwie WM. Es gibt immer wieder einen, der dann mal wieder was drüber schreibt und jetzt gibt's wieder neue Dokumente und sonst irgendwas. Dann hast du das zwei Tage, mit viel Glück zwei Tage in den Medien und dann ist es wieder weg. Dann wird einfach nicht mehr drüber gesprochen. Also ich glaube auch, das ist eine Form von Strategie, den Sport jetzt im Allgemeinen, im Fußball jetzt nochmal ganz im Speziellen sauber zu halten oder zumindest dem ein sauberes Image zu geben. Man will da nicht irgendwie drüber reden. Also von wegen irgendwie lückenlose Aufklärung, was du immer als erstes statement irgendwie machst. Wo ist es denn?
Das ist ja aber die eine Seite. Die andere Seite ist glaube ich, dass jeder Einzelne genügend Müll in seinem Leben hat, mit dem man sich auseinandersetzen muss.
Sehr wichtiger Punkt.
In der Politik, in der Gesellschaft. Du hast nur irgendwie oder denkst irgendwie, boah, das geht alles in die falsche Richtung. Es ist auch nur Beschiss irgendwo. Da musst du dich mit Sachen auseinandersetzen, wo du denkst, was soll das jetzt? Und dann will ich doch wenigstens meinen Fußball haben. Opium fürs Volk. Und da will ich mir doch wenigstens nicht Gedanken machen müssen, ob das jetzt alles so Hasen rein ist. Ich will einfach nur Fußball gucken.
Holle, ihr gebt ja völlig recht und ich glaube, das passiert gar nicht so bewusst. Das ist ein Zusammenspiel. Michl hat das gerade angedeutet. Aus einerseits denjenigen, die das Ganze institutionell betreiben, also keine Ahnung, Verbände etc. die natürlich ein Interesse daran haben, das klein zu kochen. Und den Medien, die natürlich auch gerne hätten, dass die Fußballeuphorie weitergeht, weil...
Ja, das hat das Problem. Du bist ja dein eigenes Produkt nicht schlecht.
Genau, das ist das eigene Produkt. Du bist Teil des Systems, genauso wie wir ja auch Teil, so wie Holle gesagt hat, wir sind ja auch ein kleiner Teil, aber wir sind Teil des Geschäfts.
Und dem gemeinen Fan ist es halt automatisch einfach nur recht, weil, wie du sagst, er hat vielleicht ganz andere Probleme in seinem Leben, was auch immer. Natürlich findet man es erstmal schlimm, wenn man es liest oder wenn man es mitbekommt, aber wenn man dann zwei Wochen später eben nichts mehr davon hört, weil es die Medien dann auch gern bleiben lassen, dann nimmt man das halt so hin, wie es ist. Und das Spiel war ja schon immer beliebt, weil es einfach war. Und das findet nächsten Samstag wieder statt. Und dann kann ich mir wieder damit auseinandersetzen und alles andere ist dann relativ…
Aber ganz interessant, in dem Zusammenhang, finde ich, also jetzt auch wieder irgendwie auf unsere Gäste bezogen oder was wir halt mitkriegen von unseren Gästen. Es ist so, ich denke mir halt manchmal, wie kann man zum Beispiel jetzt Fan von Hannover 96 sein bei der ganzen Geschichte rund um Martin Kind und was in diesem Verein passiert. Wenn du dich mit Hannover-Fans unterhältst, die hier sind, die gucken ihren Verein, die jubeln, die sind da voll dabei. Während einem Spiel, sprichst du die in der Halbzeitpause auf Martin Kind an, dann sagen die, geht gar nicht, will ich nicht, es ist alles eigentlich in dem Verein, das funktioniert alles nicht. Aber sie sind trotzdem voll dabei bei ihrem Verein. Auch HSV-Fans, zum Teil, wenn du die auf Kühne irgendwie ansprichst, geht überhaupt gar nicht, was da irgendwie passiert. Aber ich bin trotzdem HSV-Fan.
Schau dir letztes Jahr noch 60 an. Ich glaube gerade, der gesagt hat, der Ismaik macht das so geil, sondern alle haben geschimpft, aber sie sind halt im Herzen 60-Fans und da können sie halt nichts dagegen machen, wenn ihr Verein spielt.
Das sehen wir doch an uns selbst auch. Natürlich, ich rede auch anders über den FC Bayern, als ich seine Spiele verfolge.
Da hast du aber dann – gut, wieder ein ganz anderes Thema, aber das sind ja die Fans von ihrem Verein, die sich über ihren Verein – oder was da irgendwie auf höhere Ebene passiert, die sich darüber aufregen – aber trotzdem Fan von ihrem Verein sehen. Die regen sich aber dann trotzdem gleichzeitig drüber auf, wie man zum Beispiel Hoffenheim oder RB Leipzig-Fan sein kann, was dann wieder auch überhaupt gar nicht zusammenpasst. Und dass wir mit diesem enthusiastisch dabei sein, werden wir auch wahrscheinlich wieder sehen bei allem, was im Vorfeld über Russland WM erzählt wird. Wenn Deutschland im Halbfinale spielt, ist die Hütte voll, ist Public Wühen voll, alle hocken draußen, malen sich. Ich glaube, wir haben hier schon immer sehr schöne Farben irgendwie ins Gesicht und jubeln genauso, als wäre irgendwie nie was passiert. Das verschwindet dann irgendwie.
Ich glaube, das war einfach schon immer getrennt.
Ich hab's auch noch nie geschafft, was zu boykottieren. Ich hab mir vorgenommen, Rio zu boykottieren, die olympischen Spiele. Ich saß trotzdem vor der Glotze und hab's mir angeschaut.
Also bei mir ist es weniger geworden in olympischen Spielen. Klar, wir haben hier ein bisschen Fußball-Overload, aber wann schauen wir denn mal in Ruhe ein Spiel? Wie oft kommt denn das eigentlich vor?
Ja, gut, das ist bei uns ja was anderes. Das liegt ja wirklich daran, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Spiele ich hier schon gesehen hab. Das kann einen einfach gar nicht mehr so kicken, wie es vielleicht noch vor ein paar Jahren war. Das sind ein paar Ausnahmenspiele, die einen dann plötzlich fesseln und wo man dann trotzdem auf die Leinwand schaut. Ansonsten hören wir einen Ton.
Radio mit Bild. Oder warten auf die erste Slow-Mo.
Das ist eigentlich meistens so.
Richtig.
Das heißt, ich muss euch auch gar nicht danach fragen, wie ihr den deutschen Fußball findet und die Entwicklung, weil ihr so viel gar nicht davon mitbekommt, oder? Also ich meine jetzt auch spielerisch. Ich will jetzt gar nicht mit Europa League-Niederlagen anfangen, weil das ist, glaube ich, jetzt erstmal eine Momentaufnahme. Und ehrlich gesagt auch gar nichts überraschend, wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie bisher deutsche Mannschaften, die noch nie oder lange nicht mit dabei waren, in der Europa League geschlagen haben. Das ist halt einfach so. Aber generell ist es ja mit diesem Konterspiel, was wir inzwischen nur noch haben in Deutschland. Und das irgendwie alle können sehr gut verteidigen. Ganz, ganz wenige können aber auch mit dem Ball umgehen, wenn sie ihn mal vom Gegner bekommen haben. Da stelle ich schon immer wieder fest, hier natürlich auch meine Filterblase, aber dass die Leute sehr schnell mit Kritik da draußen sind und sagen, boah, das Kick-It kannst du hier wirklich gar nicht mal angucken. Ich schaue mir jetzt Premier League an. Wenn ich mir persönlich an Premier League-Spiele angucke, dann ist es ganz oft so, dass ich mir denke, ehrlich gesagt, das ist so jetzt eine andere Geschmacksfarbe. Aber die Grundessenz ist immer noch 80 Minuten Langeweile. 10 Minuten waren richtig aufregend. Das ist halt vielleicht auch einfach das Fußballspiel.
Ja, in der Premier League musst du eigentlich immer nur die Nachspielzeit angucken. Die ja meistens irgendwie so 10 Minuten geht. Genau. Dann geht es dann halt oft nochmal richtig ab. Genau. Das ist schon geil. Von Spielsystemen her und sowas hat sich so viel irgendwie, gerade in den vergangenen fünf bis zehn Jahren, hat sich so viel verändert, so viel Neues irgendwie dazugekommen. Auch da überlege ich mir manchmal, was kommt denn jetzt als Nächstes für ein System? Inzwischen spielt fast jeder nur noch irgendwie mit Dreierkette. Wäre ja vor ein paar Jahren noch komplett undenkbar gewesen, dann dieses typische Gelaber von nach vorne verteidigen. Ich meine, sowas gab es auch vor zehn Jahren schon oder 15 Jahren schon. Da hieß es halt dann nur anders oder wurde gar nicht irgendwie so benannt. Beziehungsweise man muss auch sagen, durch die extrem große Medienberichterstattung, die in den vergangenen zehn, 15 Jahren wirklich richtig zugenommen hat und man als Fußballinteressiert, das sage ich jetzt mal, du musst ja noch nicht mal irgendwie Fan sein, wirst du ja erschlagen von taktischen Veränderungen. Und die haben jetzt so gespielt. Ich denke es mir dann, so wie wir vorhin gesagt haben, hier Fußball schauen ist so ein bisschen wie Radio mit Bildern und du hörst halt einfach irgendwie immer nur, was der Kommentator erzählt. Da gibt es natürlich auch gute und schlechte. Es gibt welche, die sehen sofort eine taktische Veränderung. Nicht nur, wenn es eine Auswechslung gibt, sondern auch ansonsten, wenn eine Mannschaft auf irgendwas reagiert. Manche Kommentatoren sehen es. Da sitzt du dann als Fußballfan irgendwie da und denkst, okay, stimmt, das wäre mir jetzt zum Beispiel gar nicht aufgefallen. Andere kommentieren es halt dann einfach irgendwie runter. Und du hockst dann irgendwie auch, also mir geht es dann teilweise so und denkst, man merkt ja das nicht, dass die auf Dreierkette jetzt umgestellt haben oder dass sie jetzt nur noch einen Sechser drin haben. Klar, selber sieht man das, weil man halt aber auch sich irgendwie ständig damit beschäftigt. Du kannst ja echt keinen Artikel mehr jetzt lesen, ohne dass es irgendwie um eine taktische Aufstellung und dann gibt es hier wieder ein Board und dann auch was der Zone macht in der Halbzeitpause mit der taktischen Aufstellung und die Veränderung und die Laufwege und dann wirst du mit Statistiken erschlagen. Es ist vielleicht auch irgendwie schon fast ein bisschen viel und man überlegt sich ja schon manchmal, was soll jetzt als nächstes kommen? Was ist jetzt der nächste Schritt?
Eigentlich musst du ja immer noch weiter. Also du musst es ja noch weiter zerpflücken. Aber dass es manchmal halt einfach so ist, dass eine Mannschaft, die schlechter ist gegen eine Mannschaft, die besser ist, hinten drin steht und die Bälle rauskloppt, wie bei der EM zum Beispiel gesehen. Was teilweise ein ganz furchtbarer Fußball war. Aber erfolgreich. Ja klar, davor war es halt ein anderer Trend. Da war dieses Ballbesitz-Gedingse von Spanien ganz neu und toll.
Und man darf hier auch nicht vergessen, ein neues Spielsystem, Veränderung des Fußballs. Es gibt ja dann immer wieder Trainer oder Mannschaften, die auch dem wieder etwas entgegenzusetzen haben. Und so, was du jetzt irgendwie gesagt hast, da stehst du zu Zehnt hinten drin und klopst ein Ball irgendwie raus und durch einen zufälligen Konter gehst du in einzelne Entführungen und bringst es vielleicht noch irgendwie über die Zeit.
Das heißt, wir haben super gegen den Ball verteidigt.
Genau, wir haben super gegen den Ball verteidigt. Zu jedem System wird es wieder etwas geben, wie man das wieder aushebeln kann oder wie man erfolgreich dagegen sein kann. Was ich mir irgendwie finde, das hat man jetzt bei der EM zum Teil gesehen. Das siehst du ja natürlich auch zum Teil irgendwie in der Bundesliga. Auch immer dieses, was wir ja vorhin schon hatten, gibt es jetzt ein Überraschungsteam. Also Überraschungsteam heißt ja jetzt nicht, dass irgendeine Mannschaft plötzlich…
Also jemand wird überraschend sexuell.
Zum Beispiel. Genau. Das hängt, finde ich zumindest, und man sieht es zumindest aus meiner Sicht an der aktuellen Entwicklung jetzt die letzten Wochen beim FC Bayern auch, sieht man das ja auch. Es geht im Wesentlichen geht es dann trotzdem noch darum, wie es irgendwie vor 50, 60 Jahren auch irgendwie war, es muss eine Mannschaft sein, es muss ein Zusammenhalt sein, wenn sich die Spieler irgendwie gut verstehen, wenn sie sich auch irgendwie gut auf dem Platz verstehen. Das ist so, in diesem ganzen Geschäft geht es manchmal unter, dass es ja auch noch solche Vereine gibt, die irgendwie wirklich alle 20 Mann im Kader irgendwie zusammenhalten. Also ich hatte aus meiner Sicht jetzt irgendwie den Eindruck, dass es zum Beispiel beim VfB letztes Jahr in der zweiten Liga war, dass es einfach eine Mannschaft war, die sich jetzt natürlich schon wieder komplett verändert hat durch einen Aufstieg, was schon wieder ein bisschen schade eigentlich ist. Aber es ist bei Mannschaften, die dann, wie du sagst, überraschend irgendwie Sechster werden, ist es oft nicht irgendwie ein wahnsinnig tolles Spielsystem jetzt. Gut, da kann man jetzt irgendwie bei Hoffenheim Nagelsmann, der ist sicherlich ein wunderbarer Trainer irgendwie ist, aber der kann halt auch seine taktischen Vorgaben, wenn das alles Individualisten sind, funktioniert das auch nicht. Also es geht dann trotzdem wieder darum, wie der Fußball ursprünglich mal war. Elf Freunde müsst ihr sein, jetzt mal ein bisschen übertrieben. Hat schon extrem viel damit zu tun. Natürlich kommt auch Qualität dazu.
Nur eben anders, also ich würde das anders definieren. Elf gute Arbeitskollegen müsst ihr sein. Man weiß einfach, wir sind aufeinander angewiesen. Wir sind Arbeitskollegen für eine gewisse Zeit. Ich glaube, das war auch früher schon so. Und wenn es dann noch den netten Nebeneffekt gibt, dass ich mit meinem Arbeitskollegen auch noch vielleicht gerne mal irgendwo ein Trinken gehe. Perfekt. Und so davon kann...
Fußballer von heute gehen keinen mehr trinken.
Aber davon kann ja jeder, also ich gehe jetzt mal wirklich ganz weg vom Fußball. Jeder Arbeitgeber nur träumen oder Teamleiter oder was auch immer. Fangen wir bei uns hier an, mit unserem Team. Das sind 30 Leute, die sich nicht kannten. Wenn die sich jetzt untereinander nicht verstehen würden, wäre das hier ein Desaster. Die verstehen sich aber, trinken auch sehr, sehr viel Bier zusammen, gehen auch privat miteinander weg. Deswegen funktioniert das hier. Da steht jeder für einen anderen ein. So ist es wahrscheinlich in einem Team von Siemens oder sonst genau das Gleiche. Wenn man sich nicht versteht, funktioniert es nicht.
Was war denn der legendärste Abend, den ihr hier erlebt habt? Oder vielleicht wegen mir auch Nachmittag oder Mittag?
Das ist wieder eine der schwierigen Fragen.
Also für mich in meinen jetzt vier Jahren hier, sicherlich tatsächlich auch irgendwie vor knapp vier Jahren, war das ein überragender Abend mit Steppi, der einfach dreieinhalb Stunden Geschichten erzählt hat. Und eigentlich die letzte anderthalb Stunden hat er immerhin gesagt, eine Geschichte habe ich noch, dann höre ich auf. Bis seine Frau dann reingeschrien hat, er erzählt doch das noch, dann hat seine Frau noch angefangen, er erzählt doch die Geschichte noch. Und am Schluss haben wir ihn dann noch dazu genötigt, mit Mikro I Did It My Way zu singen. Also ein überragender, wirklich ein überragender Abend. Und alle die da waren, die erzählen da tatsächlich auch heute noch davon, weil es war als Lesung angedacht, wo wir ja vorher schon wussten, okay, jetzt so hoffentlich liest er da nicht so viel draus, weil so mit dem Lesen ist es ja, es ist ein nettes Buch, aber sagen wir mal so, jetzt ist journalistisch nicht besonders wertvoll. Und das war dann halt, er hat keinen einzigen Satz vorgelesen, sondern hat einfach nur Geschichten erzählt. Also das war so, würde mir jetzt spontan einfallen, obwohl es da glaube ich echt viele gibt.
Ja, in der Hinsicht, Heinz Höher, der da war, zum Buch Spieltage von Ronald Reng, der dann seine Parkinson-Tabletten nicht dabei hatte und die vorher noch durch die ganze Stadt gefahren sind, und aber keine Tabletten gekriegt haben. Und er war wirklich ziemlich zittrig, hat aber den Abend durchgezogen, irgendwie zweieinhalb Stunden, und danach war der einfach total fertig. Und hat unheimlich viel aus der Vergangenheit erzählt, Beginn der Bundesliga und so weiter. War sehr emotional. Der Auftritt von Michael Tönnies war sehr bewegend, der jetzt dann leider Anfang des Jahres gestorben ist. Genauso letztens der Auftritt von Uli Borowka, der schonungslos offen war. Das sind eben die Lesungen und so weiter, die dann gut werden, wenn die Protagonisten sich hier wohlfühlen und das hier annehmen. Und nicht sagen, naja, da geh ich jetzt hin, nimm die Kohle und erzähl was.
Ich weiß da schon bei vielen, auch so ist, die sind dann, die meisten dann zum ersten Mal da und die kommen schon hier rein und schauen sich hier um. Und ich glaube, der erste Gedanke ist, haben die einen Dachschaden hier? Also das ist so, also wenn du was mit Fußball zu tun hast und hier drin bist, musst du dich eigentlich schon irgendwie wohlfühlen und das ist dann schon die Atmosphäre. Also ich glaube, wir hatten auch, zumindest jetzt in meinen vier Jahren hier, hatten wir jetzt keine Veranstaltung, wo du gedacht hast, oh, der hat überhaupt gar keinen Bock. Der kommt vielleicht hier rein und denkt, sind die beglaubt und eigentlich habe ich ja gar keinen Bock, aber das kommt dann halt auch irgendwie während der Veranstaltung und hängt natürlich auch unmittelbar damit zusammen, wie die Gäste irgendwie darauf reagieren, was sie dann auch für Fragen stellen, dass es ja jetzt irgendwie nicht 0815-Proll-Publikum dann bei den Veranstaltungen ist, die jetzt einfach mal irgendwie einen Promi sehen wollen, sondern dass sie sich auch wahnsinnig für die Themen dann irgendwie interessieren und es ist ja im Grunde egal, was für Veranstaltungen wir machen, ob das ja unsere Ultras-Veranstaltung war, wo jetzt gar kein so Prominenter irgendwie eigentlich dabei war, aber ein wahnsinnig interessantes Thema, auch direkt aus der Szene mal irgendwie was zu hören. Wie heißt das Buch jetzt wieder von Christoph Rof?
Kurvenrebellen.
Genau, das war eine Veranstaltung in dem Sinne und da war der ehemalige Kapo vom KSC da, der so ein bisschen was erzählt hat, das waren Journalisten da.
Schikaria.
Schikaria war einer da. Das sind auch so interessante Themen, die wir immer gerne mal platzieren, was auch sehr gut bei unseren Gästen ankommt, die sich für solche Themen auch fernab von Fußballübertragungen interessieren. Wenn da dann entsprechende Feedback an Fragen kommt, wo die Gäste da sitzen und sich wirklich dafür interessieren, kommt das ja immer gut an und dann kannst du dich ja nur wohlfühlen.
Gerade aktuell, dass wir wieder nach zwei Jahren oder so Feedback gekriegt haben von dem Filmemacher Odet Breda, der den Film Ligaterre schien, also über Fußball in Theresienstadt gemacht hat. Der war jetzt irgendwie in München, wäre unheimlich gerne hierher gekommen, weil er wohl immer noch davon schwärmt, dass da 100 junge Leute saßen und sich das angeschaut haben und mit ihm darüber diskutiert haben. Leider hat seine Frau vorgezogen, aufs Oktoberfest zu gehen, deswegen konnte er nicht hierher kommen, aber er lässt uns Grüße ausrichten und sowas ist einfach immer wieder schön zu hören, weil wir uns auch an die Abende erinnern und denken, dafür lohnt sich der Aufwand.
Müsst ihr solche Lesungen und Fußballkulturelle Veranstaltungen machen oder wollt ihr das?
Aus finanziellen Gründen nicht. Also finanziell lohnt sich das nicht. Wenn es gut läuft, ist es ein Null-auf-Null-Geschäft. Wir wollen es machen, wir wollen auch so ein bisschen weg von dem stupiden, wir zeigen jetzt hier irgendwie Fußball, obwohl man das ja jetzt im Gottes Willen nicht irgendwie unterschätzen darf, aber es soll ein bisschen mehr sein, also über den Tellerrand dann halt auch hinaus und dann, ob das jetzt halt, wie ich jetzt gesagt habe, irgendwie ein lustiger Abend mit Steppi oder auch die Abende mit Frank Buschmann waren auch super, mit Wolf Fuss, was halt dann echt schon fast ein Comedy-Programm hier irgendwie ist, weil die Leute unterm Tisch liegen und lachen, aber auch halt dann eben zu ernsteren Themen wie jetzt eben Ligaterrischen ist uns extrem wichtig, sowas zu machen und das halt dann auch irgendwie anzubieten, weil wer macht es denn sonst? Also klar, es gibt Veranstaltungsorte in München, wo dann immer so irgendwie was passiert, wo es auch teilweise um Fußball geht und Buchvorstellungen von Carlo Ancelotti natürlich findet die hier nicht bei uns statt, weil da einfach irgendwie 500 Leute dann kommen, was bei uns ja gar nicht irgendwie Wenn es nicht irgendwie möglich ist, oder was jetzt, glaube ich, vor kurzem im Literaturhaus war, Matthias Sommer hat sein Buch irgendwie vorgestellt. Das macht sie dann natürlich nicht bei uns, obwohl sich es irgendwie anbieten würde. Frank Buschmann war da so die große Ausnahme, der seine Lesetour bei uns gestartet ist und der vom Management dann den Vorschlag kriegte, wir müssen in eine große Halle, weil da wird es auf jeden Fall voll. Dann hat Frank Buschmann gesagt, ist mir egal, ich will das hier machen. Dann machen wir es halt zwei Abende hintereinander. Es waren halt zweimal 130 Leute da, also wirklich komplett voll gestopft. Aber manche Sachen kannst du hier dann einfach nicht machen, weil der Andrang auch zu groß wäre. Es würde gar nicht funktionieren. Aber es ist für uns ein ganz wichtiges Thema, auch wenn wir es jetzt in letzter Zeit ein bisschen vernachlässigt haben, weil es halt auch tatsächlich ein relativ großer Aufwand ist, den da vor allem der Halle dann irgendwie betreiben muss mit der ganzen Organisation. Aber wir werden es jetzt wieder langsam angehen.
Dringend.
Das Lustige ist ja, dass ich eigentlich mit der Frage nach legendärer Abende – ich dachte, jetzt kommt dann irgendwie WM-Finale 2014, Aufstieg Stuttgart letzte Saison, aber zeigt ja schon ganz gut eigentlich, wie ihr tickt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja.
Ja, klar, die WM-Nacht war natürlich grandios, logisch, als wir Weltmeister geworden sind, als du Weltmeister geworden bist und mich auch.
Ich bin Weltmeister.
Klar war das geil.
Ich wusste jetzt tatsächlich nicht, ob du das Finale meinst oder ob du das Spiel gegen Brasilien meinst.
Das Spiel gegen, ja.
Das weiß man bei dir ja manchmal nicht.
Das stimmt. Das ist eigentlich gleichbedeutend. Klar sind es so Ausnahmen, ähm, oder auch siehst, wenn, äh, wenn der Laden wirklich explodiert. Ähm, es sind oft diese, diese emotionalen Dinge, die, äh, also bei Spielen, die einen, äh, die einen dann halt wirklich kicken. Ja, so wie…
Kann man da noch arbeiten, eigentlich? Bei so einem 7-1 gegen Brasilien, da steht mir doch… Also ich saß, ich, ich musste arbeiten zu dem Spiel und deswegen saß ich so aus einer Mischung aus kompletter Fassungslosigkeit und meine Finger haben immer getippt. Also ich musste da twittern für ein großes Unternehmen und meine Finger haben getippt. Ich war über Skype mit jemand verbunden, der in Berlin die Grafiken gemacht hat, die ich poste, und wir haben uns gegenseitig immer nur angeschrien, dass das ja total krass ist. Und ich habe dann aber relativ so, so halb emotionale…
Nee, halb emotional ging bei uns nicht. Also es gibt auch, gibt auch bei, bei YouTube legendäre Videos, mal völlig unabhängig von den ganzen Humbars, die Holle nach Deutschland siegen. Ja, immer macht, gibt es auch echt schöne, schöne Videos, ich weiß es jetzt schon wieder nicht mehr, was ist 3-0, was ich, wo ich einfach nur, Holle brüllt dann gerne mal irgendwie so ins Mikro und sagt dann die Tore an und, also wie im Fußballstadion halt und alle machen irgendwie mit und ich habe halt gedacht, ich film das jetzt einfach mal, dann haben wir wieder ein kleines Filmchen für Facebook und so was. Und während er da das Tor ansagt, fällt dann das 4-0, glaube ich. Ich dachte schon, wir wussten jetzt nicht, ist das jetzt eine Wiederholung? Wir haben einfach nur noch gelacht, also das war einfach so, wir konnten nicht mehr anders, nur noch lachen, weil es ist so surreal, es war einfach nur so komplett surreal und dann hinten raus, dann auch als es dann 7-0 stand, es haben alle nur noch irgendwie den Kopf geschüttelt und es war teilweise schon, man hat schon ein bisschen Mitleid gehabt mit den Brasilianen, aber gleichzeitig auch sich einfach nur weggeschmissen vor Lachen. Also das war, ja, kann man da noch arbeiten, ja, also ich mein, wir haben nun mal halt einfach auch diesen emotionalen Job, wir müssen einfach nicht jetzt irgendwie nüchtern reagieren. Wir müssen zum Beispiel nüchtern reagieren, wenn der FC Bayern irgendwie ein Spiel verliert, da kannst du hier mit 160 oder 150 Bayern-Fans keine Humba machen. Es kommt dann auch schon mal vor, dass wir in die Küche gehen und uns hinten in der Küche dann mal abklatschen, wenn es mal sein muss. Ohne jetzt sind Bayern-Fans zu nahe. Genau deswegen ist es ja dann immer so ein bisschen auch eine kleine Freude für uns.
Aber die Humbas, die du machst, das musst du noch erklären. Machst du das immer noch nach Hebenländisch? Wie gab es gestern nach dem Sieg gegen Aserbaiden? Gab es hier eine Humba?
Mit den 27?
Wirklich nur beiden Turnieren.
Es könnte sein, dass du heute Abend vielleicht eine Humba machst.
Auch heute Abend könnte das sein.
Hast du schon ein bisschen Isländisch gelernt?
Stimmt, das sollte ich machen. Weil der…
Isländ gegen Kosovo?
Das wird Holle gleich auch erzählen und den Satz wird er sicherlich auch sagen. Das sind wirklich so – und ich habe es leider verpasst am Freitag – aber das sind dann wirklich so schöne Abende, auch wenn jetzt der Laden nicht irgendwie bumsvoll ist, aber wenn du dann hier 30, 35 Isländer hast, die angefragt haben, ob sie das Spiel gegen die Türkei hier sehen können. Wir haben extra aufgemacht für die und dann – ich meine, es gibt ein paar Videos auf Facebook – das ist jetzt schon eigentlich irgendwie legendär so was.
Total geil. Also auch da einfach nur der ganz normale Torjubel, den wir mitgekriegt haben beim 1-0 für Island. Das ist hier großartig, wirklich großartig und 40 Leute, ganz genauer.
Nicht so wie wenn jetzt Deutschland gegen Nordirland irgendwie ist 1-0, das war es dann eigentlich. Aber für Nationen, wo es halt wirklich um was geht irgendwie und wo es auch so unerwartet irgendwie ist, auch schon eher Island bei der EM, auch mit Ungarn oder sowas, das ist halt – man ist ja dann als Neutraler auch immer dann irgendwie so für einen Underdog, aber da merkst du halt, das ist halt einfach pure Freude, weil das ist wirklich eine Sensation für die.
Vielleicht mache ich heute, wenn sie es schaffen, vielleicht für sie die Humber. Mal sehen, ob die Islander das können. Fängt ja auch mit Hu an.
Genau, du musst die wahrscheinlich beibringen.
Nein, die Humber habe ich angefangen 2008, da stand mein zufällig die ganze EM, mein alter 190er Benz draußen und irgendwann habe ich mich halt, das war sogar gleich beim ersten Spiel, wahrscheinlich möglicherweise war ich angetrunken und habe mich aufs Auto gestellt und habe bedeutet, dass alle sich hinhocken sollen und habe dann da rumgebrüllt und die Humber gemacht und immer noch irgendwas dazu erzählt und das hat sich, also zieht sich durch die Turniere.
Machst du nach jedem deutschen Sieg, steigst du aufs Autodach und machst die Humber hier vorm Stadion.
Er macht es manchmal schon gar nicht mehr irgendwie freiwillig, weil er wird inzwischen von den Gästen genötigt, weil das ist dann, das gehört dann einfach dazu.
Ja, gegen im Stadion, wenn die Spieler in die Kurve gehen und dann...
Genau, genau so.
Gegen Brasilien gab es sogar die Halbzeit Humber.
Da haben wir mal keine Schluss Humber gemacht.
Da haben wir keine Schluss Humber, da haben wir nur eine Halbzeit Humber gemacht. So arrogant waren wir da schon.
Genau, alles nachzusehen.
Natürlich beim WM Sieg, da war dann wirklich die komplette Straße voll, weil dann halt auch die Nachbarn gekommen sind und das war schon sehr geil.
Ich möchte gar nicht wissen, wie viele Videos existieren von den Nachbarn.
Ja, von irgendwelchen Dächern oder aus irgendwelchen Fenstern.
Ja, das ist meistens, also das ist tatsächlich dann bei großen Spielen dann auch so...
Da mögen sie uns.
Da mögen sie uns. Ne, auch dass da draußen dann einfach irgendwie kurzzeitig die Straße gesperrt ist, weil die Leute auf der Straße hocken, die Autos einfach stehen bleiben, in ihren Autos hocken, Fenster runter machen, anfangen zu filmen oder nur so, mit dem Scheibenwischer da sitzen. Ja, es ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen legendär geworden alle zwei Jahre. Schauen wir mal, wie viel Humpers wir nächstes Jahr machen.
Ach, das ist schon... Das sind die goldenen Momente. Da macht es immer Spaß. Und wenn ich mich jetzt angucke, ich sehe hier wahnsinnig viele Fotos auch von Leuten, mit denen ich gerne mal plauschen würde. Also direkt hinter dir, Holle, hängt Marcel Reif, Günther Koch, Sascha Bandermann, ganz viele Oli Kahn, ganz viele interessante Leute. Wie ist das, wenn man so ein Netzwerk irgendwann zu ganz vielen Fußballpersönlichkeiten hat? Kommt man da, du in deiner Twitter-Rolle als Journalist und Barbetreiber, ist eigentlich ziemlich geil der Visitenkarte.
Das Geile ist, wir haben gar kein Netzwerk. Die kommen nur hierher. Wir reden mit denen, werden auch nie eine Telefonnummer oder so von denen haben.
Da sind gerade ganz viele Tribünengesprächsanfragen gestorben.
Sondern lernen die einfach kurz kennen und dann sind wir oftmals überrascht, wie nett die alle sind. Bestes Beispiel ist Felix Magath. Da haben wir gedacht, er war mal da zu einem Filmdreh. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das war. War es die Playboy-Geschichte? Das war die Playboy-Geschichte zur EM.
Das müsst ihr noch kurz ausführen.
Das war kein Shooting. Das war schon ein bisschen ein Shooting, aber er war angezogen. Der Playboy hat zur EM im letzten Jahr ein Special gemacht und dazu ein Interview geführt mit Felix Magath, Steffen Freund und Sepp Mayer, den drei Europameistern aus ihrer jeweiligen Zeit. Sie haben das Interview hier gemacht und da ist es dann einfach auch nett, tagsüber fernab von Publikumsverkehr. Es ist dann schon ganz nett, mit denen auch mal ins Gespräch zu kommen. Wie gesagt, bei Steffen Freund war uns eigentlich klar, der ist irgendwie easy. Sepp Maier kennt man ja als Spaßvogel, aber man weiß ja nicht so wirklich, wie er irgendwie als Mensch ist. Mal außenamstlos alle drei, unglaublich nett, am wenigsten erwartet hat und was tatsächlich von Felix Maggert, weil man kennt ihn ja, wie er in Medien dargestellt wird. Und dann war der so unglaublich nett zu uns, also uns als kleine Popelwirte irgendwie, mit denen er eigentlich nicht mal irgendwie reden müsste, aber der hat sich zeitweise zu uns gestellt und hat uns komplett ausgefragt über den Laden. Also im Grunde so, wie ihr das irgendwie macht, wollte er dann irgendwie alles wissen. Und sehr lustig war dann, er war dann ein paar Wochen später für irgendeine Produktion nochmal, für ein Interview alleine da und der ist bevor zum Produktionsteam gekommen ist, ist er erstmal zu uns gekommen, hat uns die Hand geschüttelt und gefragt, wie es uns geht und ob alles weiterhin so gut läuft und sowas. Also überragend.
Da gibt es einige Beispiele.
Da gibt es sehr viele Beispiele.
Klaus Augenthaler, auch total nett oder einer unserer liebsten Promi-Gäste, Thomas Hitzelsberger. Ganz klasse, ganz klasse Typ.
Der auch gerne Interviews oder Fotoshootings dann hier macht, also der dann Interviews zusagt unter der Bedingung, dass es hier gemacht wird. Also es ist auch sehr schön für uns, also eine Form von Bestätigung.
Wenig negative Erfahrungen.
Wenig. Über die Negativen sprechen wir jetzt nicht. Du hast ja Zuhörer.
Ne, außerdem wollen wir ja hier kein Boulevard machen im Rasenfunk.
Nein, das ist ja alles von dir.
Das wäre auch nur eine subjektive Meinung gewesen.
Ja, da stellt sich für mich ja nur die Frage, wann ihr euren Podcast gründet. Allein, wenn ihr hier jede Veranstaltung aufzeichnen würdet und das verbreiten könntet, wenn das überhaupt ginge, rechtlich und so weiter, wäre doch wahnsinnig interessant für ganz viele Leute. Wahrscheinlich haben sich jetzt auch schon viele Hörerinnen und Hörer gedacht, schon ein bisschen ärgerlich, dass ich nicht in München wohne, weil dann könnte ich immer vorbeischauen.
Die sind alle herzlich willkommen. Ja, das ist ja sowieso klar.
Vor allem Island gegen Kosovo. Aber könntet ihr doch eigentlich schon machen, oder? Also generell finde ich, dass ihr auch recht defensiv seid in eurer Selbstvermarktung. Ich empfinde das als sehr angenehm, jetzt einfach so ganz subjektiv gesprochen, weil ihr könntet ja auch viel mehr Name-Dropping und so weiter betreiben, als ihr es tut. Mit fremden Födern schmücken. Ihr könntet ja jeder Promi, der hereinkommt, könnt ihr erstmal ein Selfie mit euch machen und das postet ihr auf Facebook. Aber genau das macht ihr ja nicht.
Ja, teilweise machen wir es schon. Teilweise machen wir es schon.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, nie mit den offensichtlichen Leuten. Also ich habe zum Beispiel schon gewusst, dass Mats Hummels hier häufiger herkommt. Da habe ich das noch nie von einem von euch gehört und das ist auch eher so – naja, ich kenne halt viele Leute, die halt auch häufig hier sind. Gemeinsame Freunde, würde ich mal sagen. Macht ihr es bewusst oder habt ihr gar keine Zeit dafür oder interessiert es euch noch gar nicht?
Es ist schon ein bisschen bewusst, das jetzt nicht so reizutreten. Aber wir posten schon Fotos, also das Foto mit – sind wir wieder beim Weber Flow, Sportfreunde, Stiller – werde ich auch irgendwann posten. Aber natürlich postest du es auch nur, wenn du gefragt hast, ob das okay ist. Und dann macht man das schon – klar, könnte man in der Hinsicht noch viel mehr machen oder pausen oder sonst irgendwas, aber das ist halt nicht unsere Idee.
Also offensiv machen wir das nicht. Ich meine, es gibt auf unserer Website Bilder von, grob gesagt, Gästen im Stadion, also was natürlich irgendwie mehr oder weniger prominente sind, aber damit jetzt irgendwie hausieren gehen. Also ich bin da eh nicht so der, wie sagt man so schön, Promi-geile Typ, mich interessiert. Das ist für mich ein Gast wie jeder andere oder ein Mensch wie jeder andere. Und das ist schön mit Felix Magath irgendwie zu reden oder halt gerade mit Thomas Hitzelsberg. Du hast einfach nicht die Möglichkeit.
Das ist schon ein absolutes, wir sehen es einfach eher als Privileg, dass wir mal die Möglichkeit haben.
Jemand aus dieser Welt, dann halt ein Insider im Grunde und jetzt ohne, dass man jetzt brauche, ich muss dir jetzt irgendwie was entlocken. Jetzt erzähl doch mal die Geschichte und wie war es damals und sowas. Ne, das wollen wir auch gar nicht. Wir reden ganz normal mit denen.
Ich frag ihn auch lieber, sollte jetzt Mats irgendwie demnächst kommen, wird meine Frage sein, wie läuft es mit der Schwangerschaft? Und nicht, wie war das eigentlich mit Ancelotti?
Ich wusste nicht mal ehrlich gesagt, dass Mats Hummels Freundin schwanger ist. Frau.
Ja, ich lese da ja auch eher nur die seriöse Presse, aber Holle offenbar jeden Tag die Bildzeitung. Der scheint sich da sehr gut auszukennen.
Ihr könnt ihn mal fragen, ob er den Rasenfunk inzwischen gehört hat. Auf Twitter haben jetzt eben ein paar Leute mal dazu genötigt. Frag ihn, wie läuft es mit der Schwangerschaft und hast du den Rasenfunk schon deinem ungeborenen Kind vorgespielt?
Genau, drei Stunden lang. Das wäre witzig, was das mit Kindern wohl machen würde. Ich glaube, das ist für Kinder sehr beruhigend.
Ja, das kann allerdings sein.
Die werden dann Ice-Okay-Fan oder sowas.
Ach Mensch, ich könnte irgendwie ewig mit euch noch weiter sprechen, aber irgendwann müssen wir ja auch dieses Tribünengespräch zu einem Ende bringen. Ich bin neidisch auf eure Kneipe und gleichzeitig glaube ich aber, dass der ganze Arbeitsteil, dass man den nicht unterschätzen darf. Ich weiß gar nicht, könnt ihr in Worte fassen, habt ihr oder in Zahlen fassen? 40, 50, 60 Stunden Woche wie?
Kann man eigentlich schwer sagen, weil allein mit dem Kopf ist man ja immer irgendwie dabei. Also das ist, ich kann ja auch, wenn ich Zeitungen lese, also das kommt auch ständig irgendwie vor, dass ich Holle irgendwelche Artikel dann irgendwie schicke, weil es uns irgendwie in irgendeiner Form betrifft oder weil es irgendwie interessant ist, jetzt auch im Zusammenhang und das geht jetzt nicht irgendwie darum, dass irgendwie Jupp Heynckes jetzt irgendwie Trainer wird, das kriegt er dann schon auch irgendwie selber mit, aber es gibt halt immer wieder rund um Stadion, was irgendwie mit dem Stadion zu tun hat, immer mal wieder irgendwie Artikel. Das heißt, du bist eh schon die ganze Zeit mit dem Kopf irgendwie in diesem Laden. Also Arbeitsaufwand ist halt echt schwer zu sagen.
Wenn Michl zu Hause sitzt, sollte es mal so sein, also wenn er mal freie Zeit zu Hause hat, ist mit Sicherheit sein Gedanke, oh Scheiße, gehen jetzt heute die Pommes aus oder morgen, ja, habe ich Kippen bestellt. Wenn ich zu Hause bin, renne ich trotzdem alle halbe Stunde an den PC und check, ob Mails gekommen sind, Reservierungsanfragen, die ich möglichst schnell beantworten will. Das heißt, abschalten kannst du da eigentlich nie. Funktioniert nicht, auch wenn du, wenn man mal irgendwie vielleicht privat irgendwie wohin geht. Jeder fragt danach. Das Gespräch kommt automatisch immer wieder aufs Stadion, weil das ist unser Leben und so ist es halt. Ich habe das Glück, dass ich ab und zu mittags auf den Spielplatz gehen kann, mit vielen anderen Müttern, die das Stadion halt einen Scheißdreck interessiert.
Da hat man seine Ruhe.
Da hat man echt seine Ruhe. Das ist super. Aber ansonsten eben nicht.
Na gut, jetzt haben wir ja noch glücklicherweise ein bisschen Abwechslung mit unserem neuen Wirtshaus, was so überhaupt gar nichts mit Fußball zu tun hat. Glücklicherweise. Genau, wir haben expandiert. Ja, expandiert kann man ja nicht sagen, weil das Stadion hat ja nicht expandiert, sondern wir haben expandiert. Und wie gesagt, hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun. Das stinkt normales Wirtshaus. Aber da darf jetzt Holle auch ein bisschen mit dir mit den Müttern ein bisschen was davon erzählen, die dann auch gerne regelmäßig irgendwie zum Essen kommen. Es hört irgendwie nicht auf. Und ja, mit einem zweiten Laden hat man jetzt noch mal irgendwie ein anderes Thema, aber es ist trotzdem auch irgendwie immer gastro. Und es ist halt tatsächlich so, wie Holle auch sagt, du triffst dich irgendwie mit Freunden. Also gut, die langjährigen Freunde, geht es da vielleicht noch mal irgendwie kurz irgendwie jetzt ums Stadion oder jetzt halt irgendwie um unser neues Wirtshaus. Aber sobald irgendwelche Leute dabei sind, die man jetzt vorher irgendwie nicht kannte oder nicht so gut kannte, die fangen dann immer irgendwie an einen auszufragen und wie läuft es und was macht ihr da jetzt eigentlich und stimmte es, dass der Mats Hummels schon da war. Also die üblichen Geschichten. Du redest ja nicht über mich. Du machst es ja jetzt beruflich. Andere Fragen dann halt privaten wollen dann gerne halt sind so und wie ist denn der Promi jetzt und erzähl mal und so was. Und hast du von dem die Telefonnummer, so wie du es ja auch gerade schon irgendwie angedeutet hast? Rein beruflich. Rein beruflich. Naja, aber das lässt sich einfach auch irgendwie nicht los und auf der anderen Seite muss man ja auch sagen und das fällt mir halt auch bei der Frage irgendwie nach dem Arbeitsaufwand, den wir ja haben, der schon echt enorm ist, weil man halt einfach mit dem Kopf auch nicht rauskommt. Aber es ist halt auch so, was wir hier machen, machen wir natürlich irgendwie auch, um unseren Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten. Aber in zweiter Linie halt auch, wir bieten die Möglichkeit, dass Menschen abschalten können, glücklich sein können, ihre Ruhe haben können und eben dem Alltag irgendwie entfliehen und wer kann das eigentlich so von seinem Job schon behaupten, irgendwie zu sagen, die Leute kommen zu mir, um eine gute Zeit zu haben und wir bieten einfach die Möglichkeit, also bei allem Aufwand.
Und vielleicht auch, was loszuwerden.
Und stimmt, das kommt auch dazu, ja.
Das ist so, klar kriegen wir hier auch und das ist die andere Seite dessen, dass es schön ist, aber auch traurig sein kann und sehr emotional. Wir kriegen hier natürlich auch einfach Lebensgeschichten mit, von Krankheiten angefangen bis sonst irgendwas, Schicksale. Das ist natürlich, wenn man so nah an den Leuten ist, wie wir sein wollen, ist es unweigerlich so und das ist dann nochmal die andere Sache gegenüber des Bierverkaufens.
Und trotzdem bieten wir auch denen die Möglichkeit, hier eine halbwegs gute Zeit zu verleben und vielleicht auch irgendwie ein bisschen von ihren, dass sie ein bisschen abgelenkt werden von ihren Problemen und wie gesagt, wer kann das eigentlich von seinem Job schon behaupten? Gibt sicherlich viele, aber ich glaube, der Großteil kann das nicht.
Ihr macht den Menschen auch Freude.
Ja, hoffen wir es, aber ich glaube, wo wir uns überkreuzen ist quasi, du machst deine Leidenschaft halt auch zu deinem Einkommen und dann hat das, das macht sowohl was mit deiner Leidenschaft als auch was mit deinem Einkommen, nämlich das Einkommen kleiner und die Leidenschaft wird dann manchmal auch zur Belastung, weil man den ganzen Tag dran denkt und du kannst keinen Artikel mehr lesen, ohne zu überlegen, ah, müsste ich nicht dafür zu, also bei mir, wie könnte ich das angehen, Gott, wann nehme ich die überhaupt auf und das bei euch halt auch. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man sich halt auch immer wieder klar machen, ey, ich mache das, was ich, dass ich Spaß habe, für das ich Leidenschaft habe und...
Ja, und irgendwo sind dann halt auch Grenzen, natürliche Grenzen einfach und man kann so, wie jetzt bei dir, ich meine, wir haben ja da auch schon über diverse Themen gesprochen, was du mal irgendwie, wo du mal eine Sendung dazu machen könntest, aber irgendwann geht es halt auch nicht mehr und auch deswegen auch deine Frage vorhin mit ihr, ihr müsstet ja eigentlich einen Podcast machen. Ja, sicherlich könnte man alles machen. Die Frage ist nur, wann?
Ja gut, und halt auch die Frage, für was. Nur, was, wenn man da selber total hinterher ist. Was mich ja noch interessieren würde, gibt es hier Leute, die Hausverbote haben oder anderer Frage, seid ihr für Stadionverbote?
Hausverbote?
Also mir fällt spontan einer ein, ja.
Ein Stadionverbot gibt es? Aber keine Kollektivstrafe?
Es gibt keine Kollektivstrafen. Nein, es gibt keine Kollektivstrafen, auch nicht für die Gruppe, wo der Einzelne da dabei war, der Stadionverbot hat. Also das machen wir nicht. Aber wer sich nicht an die Regeln hier hält, ist ganz schnell draußen, und zwar ganz schnell. Und das hat Holle ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen mit Respekt. Was ich ausweiten würde noch auf Respekt und Toleranz, wird hier ganz groß geschrieben, auch von uns. Und wer das nicht kann, der passt hier nicht rein und den wollen wir hier auch nicht haben.
Habt ihr das manchmal, dass hier Leute sich in der Emotion des Spiels zu homophoben oder rassistischen Kramm hinreißen lassen? Wie regelt ihr das dann?
Wir suchen das Gespräch. Also es ist teilweise so, dass die Gäste untereinander dann irgendwie regeln oder dass Gäste zu uns kommen und sagen, der hat gerade das zum wiederholten Mal. Also es ist hinreißend. Du hast es richtig gesagt. Manche lassen sich irgendwie hinreißen, was dann leider häufig auch den Charakter dahinter irgendwie ausdrückt, wenn so irgendwie was passiert. Es kann mal vorkommen. Das ist okay. Oft wird es untereinander irgendwie geregelt. Beim zweiten oder dritten Mal während einem Spiel ist dann gut. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt gemeint habe mit Respekt und Toleranz. Das wollen wir hier nicht haben und das hat hier auch überhaupt gar nichts verloren. Das hat im Übrigen in keinem Fußballstadion der Welt was verloren.
Und doch spreche ich ein Stadionverbot aus. Das kann auch durchaus als kollektiv verstanden werden. Björn Höcke, Gauland haben hier definitiv Lokalverbot.
Aber Frauke Petri darf kommen oder was?
Frauke gehört dazu. Ich sage doch Kollektivstrafe.
Hört doch nicht mehr zu dem Haufen.
Ja, das sind alles so Themen. Jetzt sind wir fast hier. Jetzt sind wir hier auf einem unangenehmen Thema rausgekommen. Das geht nicht.
Nein, da müsst ihr jetzt noch eine Frage stellen.
Nee, da muss ich auf jeden Fall noch eine Frage stellen. Also erstmal dürft ihr noch sagen, wo man euch eigentlich finden kann. Bei Facebook, Twitter und im Internet.
Bei Facebook, Twitter und im Internet.
Als Stadion alter Schleißheimer Straße.
Ja, Twitter machen wir nicht wirklich. Facebook sind wir seit Jahren sehr aktiv. Wir gestalten das Ganze eigentlich auch eher dadurch, dass wir täglich was posten, so ein bisschen mit einem lachenden Auge auf alles. Wir versuchen das so unterhaltsam wie möglich zu machen. Mit dem Hinweis, was wir an dem jeweiligen Tag für Spiele zeigen. Instagram sind wir nicht.
Du bist nicht so weit.
Ich bin nicht so weit. Social Media ist... Ja, und sonst halt Google Stadion München.
Gibt es eine Veranstaltung oder einen Gast, den ihr unbedingt mal hier haben wolltet, was noch nie geklappt hat?
Da kann der Holle jetzt ein bisschen was erzählen. Wir sind gerade tatsächlich an zweien dran, die wir tatsächlich unbedingt mal hier haben wollen.
Das werden wir auch irgendwie hinkriegen. Aber warte mal, es gab noch einen. Ansgar Brinkmann und Thorsten Matuschka – das wird hoffentlich beides funktionieren.
Ein absehbarer Zeit.
Mein Traum wird sich nie erfüllen, der hat aber auch nichts mit Fußball zu tun, dass Bruce Springsteen mal hier auftritt. Eigentlich war das Ziel, dass alle, die an der Decke hängen, also die noch nicht verstorben sind, dass die alle mal hier waren.
Frank ließ mal ein paar da kommen.
Toni Schumacher wäre zum Beispiel auch noch einer, den ich unheimlich gerne mal hier hätte.
Da hängen so die Größen des deutschen Fußballs, ne?
Habt ihr da nicht die beste Nationalmannschaft bilden wollen oder was war noch mal da?
Das war damals der Grundgedanke, aber wir haben kein Update darüber laufen lassen. Es ist immer noch Stand 2006.
Mit Seeler, Müller im Sturm, Walter, Overrad, Matthäus, Brehme, Kohle und dann hinten drin Brehme, Beckenbauer, Vogts.
Ahlenfelder als Schiedsrichter.
Ahlenfelder, ja als Schiedsrichter, klar. Ein paar waren ja schon da, Ente Lippens, Ansgar, Günter Netzer, Jimmy, Uli Borovka.
Braucht man ein Update?
Definitiv. Es braucht dringend ein Update, ja.
Definitiv. Schließlich war ja 2014 da so was.
Die Kleinigkeit ist daher passiert.
Ach, da bist du ja Weltmeister geworden.
Haben die wohl ganz gut gemacht.
Ja, gut, ein Weltmeister hängt ja hier an der Wand.
Genau, direkt neben Max hängt Mario Götze als auf der Bildtitelseite.
Wir lassen uns mal durchgehen, weil noch ein Autogramm drauf ist. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das Stadion in fünf Jahren aussieht und wie es in zehn Jahren aussieht. Vielleicht ist irgendwann dann mal die Ausstellung hier oben LED und kein Kunstrasen mehr und ihr habt eure Werte verkauft und es gibt hier einen Investor. Oder ist das alles wie jetzt? Das würde ich mir eigentlich fast wünschen.
Ich fürchte und hoffe, dass es genau so ist wie jetzt. Vielleicht mit einer anderen Mannschaft oben an der Decke.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das mal hin.
Das mag sein, ja.
Ja, man muss ja auch Ziele haben im Leben.
Man muss Ziele haben, genau.
Ihr habt ja noch ein bisschen Zeit und jetzt habt ihr mit eurer zweiten Lokalität genug zu tun.
Ja, auch das ja. Obacht geben. Obacht geben.
Obacht. Das war schon ein Hinweis auf den Namen dieses Wirtshauses. Sucht es und besucht es in München, alle Münchnerinnen und Münchern.
Dankeschön.
Ich danke euch sehr. Vielen, vielen Dank, Holle. Vielen Dank, Michl.
Das hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Wir haben zu danken für das Interesse.
Und irgendwann machen wir hier auch mal ein Hörerinnen- und Hörer-Treffen. Nicht Hörerinnen-oder-Hörer-Treffen, sondern Hörerinnen-und-Hörer-Treffen, dürft ich.
Ja, aber auch mal was Schönes. Eine reine Frauenveranstaltung.
Na, es passen ja nur 130 rein insofern. Müssen wir halt zwei abnehmen.
Müssen wir halt zwei Abnehmen nacheinander machen. Sehr, sehr schön, Frank. Ja, vielen Dank euch für eure Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt. Vielen Dank allen Hörern und Hörern fürs Zuhören. Hört auch die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz und den Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Sollte das hier vielleicht die erste Folge gewesen sein, die ihr gehört habt.
Und unterstützt uns.
Und unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Könnt ihr zu Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und – supportern werden. Und dann freuen wir uns sehr über jeden, der mit dabei war. Frank, ich danke auch dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Ich danke.
Freut mich mir sehr, wenn wir es zu zweit machen können. Und dann würde ich sagen, folgt uns auf Facebook, folgt uns auf Twitter, folgt uns auf YouTube, folgt uns sogar auf Instagram. Wir sind krass weit vorne mit dabei, Holle.
YouTube sind wir auch, YouTube.
Ja, stark, YouTube. Starten an der Schleißheimer Straße.
Das letzte Video ist von vor fünf Jahren, oder so.
Nein, nicht ganz so schlimm. In diesem Sinne, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.